über das Haushaltsgesetz 2023 stimmen
wir später namens dich ab
für die Aussprache wurde eine Dauer von
90 Minuten beschlossen ich eröffne die
Aussprache ja meine Damen und Herren und
jetzt also am Ende einer haushaltswoche
wie das üblich ist noch einmal eine
90-minütige Aussprache über den
Gesamthaushalt und der erste Redner ist
Helge braun der Vorsitzende des
Haushaltsausschusses von der cdu/cs
schon in der ersten lesungsrunde haben
erfahrene Haushälter gesagt diese
Haushaltsberatungen die werden aufwendig
werden und alles andere als einfach eine
Krise mit so vielen Herausforderungen
und darüber hinaus auch die Inflation
das wird viel Arbeit werden und so war
es auch die Änderungsliste alleine der
Regierung gegenüber dem Haushaltsentwurf
war 500 Seiten stark und damit ziemlich
rekordverdächtig aus den Reihen der
verschiedenen Fraktionen haben wir in
der Bereinigungssitzung
1498 Anträge behandelt und wir haben
insgesamt über den Zahlen dieses
Haushaltes 67 Stunden und 20 Minuten
gebrütet alleine die Bereinigungssitzung
die letzte Sitzung hat von 11 Uhr
vormittags bis 5:38 Uhr gedauert das
sind mehr als 18 Stunden
ich möchte mich bei allen Kolleginnen
und Kollegen ganz herzlich bedanken für
die konzentrierte und faire
Zusammenarbeit darüber hinaus bei den
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern der
Abgeordneten der Fraktionen des bmbf@bmf
und ganz besonders natürlich bei unserem
Ausschuss der kriteriat weil bei diesen
ganzen vielen Änderungsanträgen dass wir
heute hier stehen und sagen können wir
haben präzise festgehalten was wir
beschlossen haben und es ist in bis auf
die letzte Zahl klar worüber wir
abstimmen das ist eine große Arbeit und
deshalb den Mitarbeitern unseres
Ausschuss Sekretärs und ganz herzliches
Dankeschön
ich will einen Punkt ansprechen der
unsere Arbeit aber auch erschwert hat
und wo ich die Bundesregierung herzlich
bitte auch darüber noch mal nachzudenken
wir haben in dieser Zeit der Krisen ist
regelmäßig damit zu tun dass wir
kurzfristige entscheidungsbedarfe haben
dieses Parlament hat gezeigt und ich
habe das mehrfach gesagt und ich glaube
da spreche ich auch für alle Haushälter
wenn es wirklich an der Zeit ist
kurzfristig zu entscheiden und
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in der Not bei
Inflation oder irgendwas zu helfen dann
ist der Haushaltsausschuss jederzeit
bereit innerhalb von Tagesfrist
innerhalb von 48 Stunden Entscheidungen
zu treffen an dem parlamentarischen
Abläufen wird das notwendige niemals
scheitern
auf der anderen Seite
haben wir in den letzten Tagen aber auch
erlebt dass die Ankündigung der
Bundesregierung schon sechs Wochen alt
sind das Dinge wie zum Beispiel die
testverordnung und Falke Corona seit
sechs Wochen zur Überarbeitung ansteht
dass dann fünf Wochen und vier Tage die
Bundesregierung sich Zeit lässt die
Dinge vorzubereiten um dann vom
Parlament zu erwarten dass man innerhalb
von drei Tagen die Dinge entscheidet und
da sage ich das kritisiere ich nicht aus
eher puzzellichkeit des Parlamentes
sondern hier geht es um die Qualität von
Gesetzgebungen die Frage ob Experten ob
Länder ob Anhörungen stattfinden können
das am Ende das Ergebnis unserer
Rechtsetzung gut ist und wenn das die
Aufgabenteilung im zeitlichen Sinne ist
dann ist das falsch und deshalb egal wie
kurz die Frist ist dass man dem
Parlament wenigstens auch ein Drittel
der Zeit lässt und die eigenen Beratung
durchzuführen das hielte ich
veranständig und darum möchte ich die
Bundesregierung eindringlich bitten
dieser Haushalt liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ist schon jetzt auf Kante
genäht ich will noch ansprechen der
Bundesfinanzminister Christian Lindner
hat eines vorgehabt nämlich fünf
Milliarden als globale Mehrausgabe auf
die Seite zu legen für all die Probleme
die noch kommen weil ansonsten die
haushaltsspielräume komplett
ausgeschöpft sind in der
Bereinigungssitzung ist diese Summe
schon von fünf auf zwei Milliarden
gesunden und der
haushaltsausschusssitzung dieser Woche
haben wir gemerkt dass wir für die eben
schon genannte testverordnung schon 1,2
Milliarden davon belegen müssen das
heißt wir gehen mit einem Haushalt den
wir heute beschließen los der für all
die Unbilden der Krisen des kommenden
Jahres keine Vorsorge trifft das halte
ich für problematisch
einen letzten Punkt weil er in dieser
Haushaltsberatung immer wieder eine
große Rolle gespielt hat nämlich das
Sondervermögen Bundeswehr und die
Haltung des Bundeskanzlers dazu möchte
ich noch thematisieren der Bundeskanzler
ist der mannschaftschef dieser
Bundesregierung und wer die
Kapitänsbinde trägt der hat nicht nur
die Aufgabe und die Verantwortung
sportlich sein Team nach vorne zu
bringen sondern er hat noch eine zweite
Aufgabe nämlich im besonderen Weise
Fairness und Sportlichkeit auch
gegenüber dem Gegner walten zu lassen
und Olaf Scholz hat als Bundeskanzler
mehrfach betont dass seine Regierung
jetzt beim Sondervermögen Bundeswehr all
das aufarbeiten muss was die alte
Regierung nicht geschafft hat und als
jemand der der ehemalige Bundesregierung
genauso angehört hat wie Olaf Scholz
kann ich sagen ja auch Annegret
Kramp-Karrenbauer Angela Merkel und ich
wir müssen den Soldatinnen Soldaten
sagen wir haben uns zwar mehr Geld für
die Bundeswehr und ein klares be kann es
zum 2% Ziel gewünscht
und wir sind dafür verantwortlich dass
wir es nicht durchgesetzt haben aber
derjenige gegen den wir nicht mehr
durchgesetzt haben und derjenige der im
Bundeshaushalt sich dagegen gewehrt hat
dass wir das zwei Prozent Ziel klar
reinschreiben sondern stattdessen Wolke
die Formulierungen von Richtung 1,5
Prozent das war der Bundesfinanzminister
Olaf Scholz und deshalb hat er eine weit
größere Verantwortung dafür dass wir
heute in dieser Lage sind wir waren des
guten Willens und er ist derjenige an
dem wir da gescheitert sind und deshalb
will ich deutlich sagen ein
Mannschaftskapitän muss sportlich
Vorbild sein er macht der Kapitänsbinde
keine würde vielen Dank
Helge braun von der CDU der Vorsitzende
des Haushaltsausschusses er hat es
angesprochen eine 18-stündige
Bereinigungssitzung das ist nicht so
spektakulär wie sich es anhört ist es
sehr sehr lange aber die Haushälter
haben immer diese Bereinigungssitzung
die meistens auch sehr lange dauert über
1.000 Anträge und dort ist viel Geld
bewegt worden unter anderem 31
Milliarden mehr beschlossen worden als
vorher festgelegt worden war Bettina
stellvertretende Vorsitz im
Haushaltsausschuss sie ist von der
spdsbinder die hat in unserem
Haushaltsausschuss in den letzten acht
Wochen der Beratung die hast du ja
getragen und ich glaube ich spreche für
alle Haushälter wenn ich hier an dieser
Stelle feststelle ein dickes Dankeschön
geht an unseren
haushaltsausschussvorsitzenden der den
Haushaltsausschuss
Applaus von allen Fraktionen mit sehr
viel Ruhe Kompetenz aber auch sehr viel
Stringenz durch diese Wochen geleitet
hast du hast so Recht darauf hingewiesen
wie viele Seiten wie viele
Änderungsanträge es waren es war ein
ganz
bemerkenswerter Haushalt das war meine
21 Bereinigungssitzung und es ist schon
so dass natürlich in Zeiten wo zwischen
dem Kabinettsbeschluss für ein Haushalt
und der Bereinigungssitzung sich die
Welt so dramatisch verändert wie in
diesem Jahr da kommt es dann auch zur
umfangreichen veränderungs
Erfordernissen beim Haushalt aber wir
haben das gut bewältigt und vielen Dank
für deine kluge Führung an dieser Stelle
das war jetzt
das war jetzt aber genug Lob
denn die behälge Braun du hast gerade
eben auf das 2% Ziel angesprochen und
darum will ich jetzt doch mal ein
bisschen etwas dazu sagen auch wenn ich
sicher bin mein Kollege an die schwarze
das nachher noch näher ausführen fakt
ist jedenfalls
dass wir in der zweiten groko als der
Finanzminister Wolfgang Schäuble ist ein
Verteidigungsetat hatten der so zwischen
im ist zwischen 36 und 37 Milliarden
Euro nach
vier Jahre später als wir die große
Koalition die dritte hatten mit Olaf
Scholz als Finanzminister hatten wir den
Etat pro Jahr auf über 50 Milliarden
gesteigert das ist pro Jahr ein Plus von
13 Milliarden Euro und was das in der
Summe was das in der Summe für das für
die Ausstattung für die Bundeswehr
bedeutet dass es bemerkenswert und
insofern hör auf mit der mehr
Sozialdemokraten hätten hier gestoppt
dass wir für die Ausrüstung der
Bundeswehr und der Soldaten und Soldaten
genug Geld bereitstellen dafür waren wir
immer allerdings die Träume von Annegret
Kramp-Karrenbauer Deutschland mit einem
Flugzeugträger ausgestatten das war
nicht hatte ich auf unsere Begeisterung
gestoßen
liebe Kolleginnen liebe Kollegen dieser
Haushalt trägt aus unserer Sicht die
Überschrift Zusammenhalt in der
Zeitenwende und wir haben in dieser
Woche ein Haushalt beschlossen der nicht
nur vom Volumen her enorm ist sondern
der auch auf die Erfordernisse der Zeit
die richtigen Antworten gibt in allen
Haushalten die wir hier auf Natz also
die nationale Tragweite haben haben wir
enorme Aufstockung beschlossen in dem
Umfang wie sie wirklich erforderlich
sind ich sag nur wir haben auf die
berechtigten Sorgen der Jobcenter gehört
wir haben den Etat für Arbeit und
Soziales zum Beispiel um 500 Millionen
Euro nur in diesem Bereich für die
aktive
Arbeitsmarktpolitik aus aufgestockt wir
werden dafür Sorge tragen dass gerade in
diesen Zeiten nicht nur die
Arbeitsplätze gesichert bleiben sondern
auch dass Menschen in Qualifizierung
kommen um dann auch qualifizierte
Arbeitsplätze zu haben wir haben uns
aber auch um die Sorgen der Menschen
gekümmert nicht nur die drei entlastungs
Pakete von fast 100 Milliarden Euro sind
voll finanziert in diesem Haushalt
sondern auch viele viele Dinge ich nenne
nur beispielhaft die größte
Kindergelderhöhung ab 1 Januar überhaupt
auf 250 Euro pro Kind ich nenne nur das
Wohngeld plus dass die
wohngeld-empfänger die
Anspruchsberechtigten verdreifachen wird
und das Wohngeld verbessern wird und all
dies in Beiträge die wir heute mit
diesem Haushalt beschließen und liebe
Kolleginnen liebe Kollegen insbesondere
die die diesem Haushalt zustimmen werden
also die Kolleginnen und Kollegen von
FDP und Grüne darauf können wir
gemeinsam stolz sein
und es ist auch wichtig dass wir diesen
Haushalt des Zusammenhalts in der
Zeitenwende nicht nur auf nationaler
Ebene betrachtet haben und auf
internationale Ebene nicht nur die
Bundeswehr im Blick hatten sondern dass
wir auch den Etat der Außenministerin
der den Etat der Ministerin für
wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit und
Entwicklung um jeweils eine Milliarde
aufgestockt haben und zusätzlich in der
Bereinigungssitzung aus den Mitteln des
Haushalt des 2022 eine weitere Milliarde
Paris zwischen diesen beiden Ressorts
aufgeteilt zur Verfügung gestellt haben
das sind Beiträge zum Beispiel um die
internationale Ernährungssicherheit
sicherzustellen und die wirken erst im
kommenden Jahr und das ist wichtig und
erforderlich und damit wir Deutschland
sein Beitrag leisten in der Welt denn
die Welt guckt auf uns natürlich ob wir
auch in militärischer Hinsicht konstant
und zuverlässig sind aber sie guckt auch
da drauf ob wir unsere Rolle gerecht
werden die wir in der g7-präsidentschaft
immer wieder bekräftigt haben wir stehen
für Dialog wir stehen für Unterstützung
wir stehen für Solidarität mit der
Ukraine aber was mir wichtig auch ist
auch mit den Anrainerstaaten wie
Moldawien oder Polen die viel viel mehr
Flüchtlinge aufgenommen haben als wir
und darum bin ich sicher dass wir gut
gewappnet sind mit diesem Etat und ich
bedanke mich bei allen die dazu
beigetragen haben und auch ich möchte
mich ganz besonders bei unseren
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern des
Ausschuss Sekretärs bedanken vielen Dank
die Haushälter einer verschworene
Gemeinschaft hier im Deutschen Bundestag
alle wissen was Sie geleistet haben und
vorhin gab es beim Lob an Helge braun
tatsächlich Applaus aus allen Fraktionen
auch von Peter böhringerdem
afd-haushaltspolitischen Sprecher der
jetzt das Wort hat
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin Liebe Steuerzahler
übermorgen ist erster Advent und die
Regierung hat einen Adventskalender
gebastelt öffnen wir die 24 Türchen
die Erweiterung des Bundeskanzleramts
wird durchgezogen die Ampel verteidigt
dass 770 Millionen Euro Projekt obwohl
sie die Planungen noch stoppen könnte
doch Herr Scholz will es ebenso
gigantomanisch wie Frau Merkel haben
die Ampel gönnt sich seit Amtsantritt
10.000 Stellen aufwuchs in ihren
Bundesbehörden meine übertrifft damit
inmitten einer bevorstehenden Rezession
sogar noch die Vorgängerregierung
auch der Bundestag selbst bekommt fast
70 zusätzliche Stellen 2023 das stark
linkslastige Institut für Menschenrechte
bekommt sogar 50 Prozent
personalaufwuchs
6 Milliarden Euro für den neuen IWF vor
resilience and the stayability trust
alles für internationale Corona und
Klimafinanzierung 24 Milliarden fürs
Bürgergeld davon über 10 Milliarden an
ausländische Empfänger
30 Milliarden klimaausgaben aus dem KTF
Kanzler Scholz versprach zudem am 6
November in einer fünf Minuten rede mal
eben ein weiteres milliardenprogramm
fürs Klima für den Planeten mit mehr
Ehrgeiz und Zusammenarbeit mit den
Staaten der Welt mehr Ehrgeiz also gegen
den deutschen Steuerzahler denn
natürlich ist er seine Schiffe für
Deutschland zahlt es
zudem mehr Unterstützung durch
gelegenheitsstrom aus Sonne und Wind für
den Balkan
hinzu kommen absurde eu-klimaprogramme
über die die grüne co2-religion in allen
EU-Ländern durchgesetzt werden soll das
selbe macht die Ampel sogar in Moldawien
und Georgien bei deutschen Verbrauchern
dürfen sich die Energierechnung dagegen
verfünffachen das stört die Ampel nicht
die Ukraine forderte im November mal
eben die Finanzierung ihres
Staatshaushalts die Finanzierung des
ganzen Staatshaushalts die zugehörige
gebekonferenz fand darum gleich hier in
Berlin statt denn ja dann konnten die
deutschen Steuerzahler oder im Namen der
deutschen Steuerzahler die großzügigen
Geber kurze Wege haben in Berlin hier
letztlich ist eine signifikante
Übernahme der Ukraine kriegs- und
Haushaltskosten durch die internationale
Gemeinschaft also Deutschland offenbar
gesetzt bis hin zur 750 Milliarden ist
da alles möglich da die Bundesregierung
ja schon früh einen Blankoscheck
unterschrieben hat
Rüstungsgüter werden dabei oft indirekt
gekauft oder getarnt als Gewährleistung
etwa über die European peace facility
der EU oder über ibf-konstruktion dabei
weiß man natürlich schon heute dass das
Geld niemals zurückfließen wird trotzdem
fordern die Ministerinnen bärburg und
Lambrecht der einzigen Friedenspartei in
grüne und SPD noch mehr Geld für Waffen
für die Ukraine
kohleersatzindustrien man versucht
angeblich die Zukunft der alten
kohleregionen zu sichern leider jedoch
indem man technologische Sackgassen dort
ansiedelt ich sage das ganz bewusst
wasserstoffprojekte in der geplanten
Form sind Sackgassen oder für die viele
Millionen Euro ernsthaft ein Institut
für elektrifizierte luftfahrtantriebe
oder gar eine Initiative Hybrid
elektrisches fliegen ich sage Ihnen das
ist eine vollabschreibung vom ersten Tag
an
generell wäre es natürlich besser die
alte Industrie an diesen Standorten gar
nicht ist kaputt zu schlagen sondern sie
ganz konservativ Konserve zu bewahren
deutsche Kohle wird ja zunehmend wieder
weltmarktfähig und auch gebraucht aber
die Züge die grüne CO2 Religion steht
halt im Weg
die permanente uniper-rettung die größte
unternehmensrettung der deutschen
Geschichte ständig wachsende Kosten
Kredite eigenkapitalgeschenke und
Gewährleistung des Bundes an Juniper und
Ablösung von wertlosen finnischen
altkrediten alles in Milliardenhöhe
inzwischen über 50 Milliarden Euro alles
völlig intransparent und das ist immer
noch nicht das Ende der Rechnung
hinzu kommen Milliardenverluste aus
gasthermien Geschäften der Trading
soll keine zockergeschäfte mit
grundlosem Gasverkauf auf Termin machen
sondern das teuer mit Steuergeld
eingekauft und eingelagerte Gas einfach
exklusiv für die deutsche Stadtwerke
vorhalten leider geschieht das nicht und
wir haben es im Ausschuss ausführlich
erfragt aber es geschieht nicht man
lockt lieber über terminmarktverkäufe
ohne Not und zum denkbar ungünstigsten
Zeitpunkt den maximalverlust für den
deutschen Steuerzahler und zugleich
maximal Gewinne für internationale
Terminmarkt ca ein ohne sicherzustellen
dass das Gas wenigstens die deutschen
Verbrauchern zugute kommt ein Skandal
[Applaus]
dann absurd hohe 670 Millionen Euro für
die politischen Stiftungen die AFD
fordert seit Jahren einen drastischen
abwuchs dieser Position und wir sind
noch immer nicht fertig hier weitere
steuergeldt Türchen die nicht nur
überflüssig sondern sogar schädlich für
Deutschland sind der Verein United for
rescue erhält bis 2026 über 8 Millionen
Euro Steuermittel zur Schleusung von
asylforderern an die europäische Küste
und damit natürlich nach Deutschland
hier gilt gute Taten mit fremdem Geld
haben keinerlei moralischen Wert die
Deutschen wollen diese Summe nicht für
diesen Zweck eingesetzt werden
und schon gar nicht per Vettern
Wirtschaft in der Vorsitzende des
Vereins ist ja inzwischen bekanntlich
der Lebensgefährte der
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin Göring-Eckardt
diese Position sagt sehr viel über den
moralischen Wert des Gesamthaushalts aus
mit einigen Millionen unterstützen sie
als Steuerzahler auch noch solche netten
Dinge wie
finanzsystemreformen in Marokko oder
urbane Mobilität in Peru steht alles
hier und natürlich unterstützen Sie auch
immer noch die corona-hysterie mit
Milliarden für Tests in Impfdosen
Minister Lauterbach lässt einfach nicht
locker obwohl die corona-maßnahmen nicht
etwa non-kovic das ist eine Lüge
höchstwahrscheinlich seit 2021 zu einer
signifikanten Übersterblichkeit geführt
haben
dann zahlen Sie künftig den Leib und
hochfotografen von Minister Habeck mit
sechsstelligem Jahresgehalt die AFD weiß
warum sie die Öffentlichkeitsarbeit der
gesamten Regierung fast alle Ministerien
drastisch reduzieren will und dann noch
das Adventstürchen 24 mit Millionen von
Euro werden von der CO2 besorgten
Regierung riesige landwirtschaftliche
Nutzflächen die unsere Vorfahren in
Jahrhunderten und vor Jahrhunderten den
Sumpflandschaften entrissenen abgerungen
hatten wir da wieder unter Wasser
gesetzt das ist kein Witz der Ampel ist
also zukünftig mit Kapitänsbinde in
neuen Sümpfen unterwegs den alten
politium bewässert sie ja sowieso
Milliarden schwer verrücktes Deutschland
21 22 ich konnte zum Schluss das war nur
24 kleine Spitzen der Eisbergen kleine
Einblicke in die Tiefen der Abgründe die
sich im linken links-haushalt auftun
überall und für alles ist Geld da nur
nicht für Werktätige deutsche ich
wünsche Ihnen trotzdem einen schönen
ersten Advent aller
[Applaus]
das Wort hat Dr Paula piechotta für die
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Liebe
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer 2023 wird
es dritte Jahr in Folge sein dass nach
einem krisenhaushalt verlangt und wir
gewöhnen uns nicht als Parlament an den
Ausnahmezustand aber wir können
inzwischen ganz gut mit ihm umgehen wir
wissen unter anderem umso
unübersichtlicher die Zeiten umso klarer
müssen die Antworten sein und die
Antworten die dieser Bundeshaushalt gibt
in Sachen Entlastung in Sachen
Modernisierungen Sachen
Energiesicherheit die sind sehr klar in
unübersichtlichen Zeiten wir wachsen
wir wachsen an unseren Aufgaben in der
Krise als Gesellschaft als Bundestag und
auch der Bundeshaushalt wächst mit uns
an diesen großen Aufgaben Friedrich Merz
am Mittwoch und auch Jens Spahn zum
Beispiel heute Vormittag hier die können
ja gar nicht die aktuelle Situation in
Deutschland schwarz genug malen und es
ist ihr gutes Recht das als Opposition
so zu sehen aber ich möchte auf ein paar
frühen die katoren verweisen die
vielleicht auch deutlich machen dass ich
vielleicht gerade die Stimmung auch ein
bisschen dreht manche meiner Kollegen
würden auf den ifo Geschäftsklimaindex
hinweisen der den zweiten Monaten
vollgesteigt andere auf die deutlich
reduzierenden Energiepreise ich möchte
Ihnen aber noch einen anderen früh in
die Kater nennen der für mich Verein in
meiner Region wichtig ist ein ganz
feiner Gradmesser dafür wie groß die
materiellen Ängste in dieser
Gesellschaft sind und das ist das
Demonstrationsgeschehen in
Ostdeutschland wir stellen in diesen
Wochen fest weniger Demonstrationen
weniger Teilnehmerinnen bei den
verbliebenen Demonstration und man muss
sagen dieser heiße Herbst den sich so
viele in feuchten Fieberträumen
gewünscht haben der kommt nicht der wird
still und heimlich beerdigt und das ist
ein gutes Zeichen für den Zusammenhalt
in dieser Gesellschaft und da hat auch
der Bundeshaushalt Anteil daran
was finde ich märz und was auch Jens
Spahn heute morgen ja auch nicht oft
genug betonen können ist dass es aus
ihrer Sicht ruckelt in der
Bundesregierung ruckelt ich möchte
fragen kann es vielleicht sein dass sie
in der Union vielleicht einfach nicht
mehr wissen wie es sich anfühlt wenn
sich was bewegt in diesem Land es
ruckelt ja vor allen Dingen deswegen
weil so lange Stillstand war wir machen
den Monaten was vorher Jahrzehnte nicht
ging
und an der Stelle an der Stelle die
Frage zu stellen ist es vielleicht auch
gut dass mal was ruckelt weil neue Wege
auch nach Streit verlangen um diese
neuen Wege überhaupt erst definieren zu
können die man hier beschreiten will
und dann auch bei Friedrich Merz und
Jens Spahn ist ja auch der Vorwurf nicht
weit das würde es wäre hier
führungsversagen der Bundesregierung
ganz ehrlicherweise muss ich sagen es
gibt gerade genug Beispiele auch in
Europa für echtes führungsversagen wenn
wir nach Großbritannien schauen 44 Tage
von List fast die haben gezeigt was
wirklich an verheerenden Folgen da als
wenn echtes führungsversagen Haushalts
und finanzpolitische Verwerfungen
produziert was die DFB gerade in Katar
abliefert auch echtes führungsversagen
und wenn ich ganz kurz noch mal auf die
CDU schauen will die CDU als mit Abstand
größte konservative Parteien in diesem
Land und das sage ich auch als jemand
der aus Sachsen kommt eine der
vornehmsten Aufgaben der größten
konservativen Partei gerade auch als
Lehrer aus dem 20 Jahrhundert ist
führungs zu zeigen Führung die Friedrich
Merz auch bei Amsterdam angekündigt hat
als Partei dafür zu sorgen dass die
Brandmauer gegen Rechts auch in diesen
Krisenzeiten stehen bleibt und dass sie
gehegt und gepflegt wird und jeder ist
der Auftritt sofort zugespachtelt wird
und dann führungsversagen zu reden wenn
man in der eigenen cdu/csu es nicht
schaffen ostdeutsche CDU lass ich im
bundesdeutschen Fernsehen hinstellen und
Friedrich Merz persönlich mit dem
Schicksal von Marie Antoinette Drohnen
wenn er weiter auf dieser Brandmauer
besteht dann erwarte ich auch von
Friedrich Merz als Parteivorsitzende
dass an der Stelle die Kapitänsbinde
nicht so schräglich abstreift wie das
der DFB tut dass er nicht einfach nur
den Mund hält sondern dass er den Mund
aufmacht wenn es unangenehm wird das ist
seine Aufgabe in diesen Zeiten für den
Erhalt der Demokratie weil ich will in
20 und in 30 Jahren
apropos Kapitänsbinde man hat ja jetzt
gestern auf Twitter gelesen die soll
jetzt schon ins Haus der Geschichte
überführt werden ehrlich gesagt glaube
ich nicht dass ich in 20 oder 30 Jahren
wenn wir diese Demokratie erfolgreich
durch die Krise gebracht haben das wird
uns dann Armbinden aus Polyester
anschauen wollen im Haus der Demokratie
sondern die Modernisierungsprojekte die
auch in diesem Haushalt schon angelegt
sind die automatisierte digitale
Kupplung die den Eisenbahngüterverkehr
revolutionieren wird vielleicht auch der
erste mRNA Impfstoff gegen Krebs der in
Deutschland hergestellt wird das sind
glaube ich die Sachen die wir im Haus
der Geschichte in 30 und 40 Jahren sehen
wollen und meine Damen und Herren Krisen
sind Katalysatoren für Modernisierung
und Krisen sind Katalyse Katalysatoren
dafür dass wir unglaublich schneller
Schritte vorwärts machen in dieser
Gesellschaft und ganz ehrlich dieser
Bundeshaushalt ist Teil dieser
katalysatorischen Wirkung und ich freue
mich auf die vielen Modernisierungen die
wir auch im nächsten Jahr schon werden
beobachten können vielen herzlichen Dank
Schlussrunde im Deutschen Bundestag zum
Haushaltsgesetz 2023 und Gesine lötz die
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
ist auch Berichterstattungen für ihre
Fraktion und haushaltspolitische
Sprecherin ich glaube sie ist die
Abgeordnete die in den letzten vier
Tagen hier am häufigsten am Rednerpult
stand
als er ist nicht friedlich und er ist
auch ökologisch darum werden wir linken
in ablehnen meine Damen und Herren er
ist nicht sozial weil die har
Steuererhöhung nicht einmal die
Inflation ausgleicht die Gründen
Nahrungsmittel sind über 20 Prozent
gestiegen die Preise und 11 Prozent
Erhöhung von Hartz IV ist da ein
schlechter Witz meine Damen und Herren
wir sagen weg mit der Mehrwertsteuer auf
Lebensmitteln und er ist nicht sozial
weil er unser Gesundheitssystem in den
Grundfesten erschüttert die
gesundheitliche Versorgung ist nicht
mehr gesichert wenn Krankenhäuser und
Arztpraxen weiter ungeschützt der
Preisexplosion ausgesetzt werden wir
sagen kein Krankenhaus darf geschlossen
werden meine Damen und Herren
und der Haushalt ist nicht sozial weil
er die Krisengewinner nicht zur Kasse
bittet die Unternehmensberatung
ernst-dax-firmen im Vergleich zum
Vorjahreszeitraum sind um 23 Prozent
gestiegen und damit so stark wie seit
zehn Jahren nicht mehr das ist doch
nicht normal wir brauchen endlich eine
übergewinnsteuer meine Damen und Herren
und dieser Haushalt meine Damen und
Herren ist nicht auf Frieden
ausgerichtet 72 Milliarden Euro
insgesamt sollen für Aufrüstung
ausgegeben werden die Rüstungskonzerne
verdienen sich dumm und dämlich und die
Ampel ist bereit jeden Preis für Waffen
und Munition zu zahlen die
Schuldenbremse gilt augenscheinlich
nicht für die Bundeswehr sie wird nur
dann angezogen wenn es um Gesundheit
Bildung und Wohnen geht wollen Sie etwa
eine Koalition der sozialen Kälte
bleiben meine Damen und Herren
und diese Regierung ist auch nicht
ökologisch sie haben beim Einkauf von
Gas und Öl nur die Oligarchen gewechselt
dafür zahlen sie jetzt auch jeden Preis
und wenn man jetzt Steinkohle aus
Südafrika einkauft dann ist es ja wohl
auch nicht der kürzeste Weg meine Damen
und Herren es ist schon erstaunlich wie
die schwindsüchtige FDP den Kurs dieses
regierungstankers vorgibt wenn ich eine
Kapitänsbinde wenn ich eine
Kapitänsbinde in dieser Regierung zu
vergeben hätte würde sie Herr Lindner
bekommen die FDP ist nämlich die einzige
Partei die die Wünsche ihrer Wählerinnen
und Wähler eins zu eins durchsetzt sie
verhindert eine gerechte Steuerreform
die FDP und die Krisengewinner haben
sich untergehakt das gefährdet den
sozialen Frieden in unserer Gesellschaft
die Politik muss ich umkehren vielen
Dank meine Damen und Herren
ja ein Lob was als solches ja nicht
unbedingt so gemeint ist aber das hat
sie in dieser haushaltswoche schon
einmal von sich gegeben mal sehen was
Christian Lindner dazu sagt der
Finanzminister der den Etat zu
verantworten hat denn er hat jetzt das
Wort
herr Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen liebe Kolleginnen lötz vielen
Dank für die Worte der Anerkennung liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen insbesondere
den Mitgliedern des Haushaltsausschusses
will ich danken für
intensive
arbeitsreiche und sehr konstruktive
Beratungen die Kolleginnen und Kollegen
des Haushaltsausschusses haben wahrlich
gezeigt dass sie keine Leichtmatrosen
sind in dieser stürmischen See in diesen
für uns alle herausfordernden Zeiten
haben sie einen Haushalts Entwurf
beraten und jetzt hier auch zum
Beschluss vorgelegt der Orientierung
gibt in diesen schwierigen Zeiten
gewissermaßen haben die
Haushaltspolitiker die
Kapitänsbinde angezogen um diesem Land
mit diesem Haushalt Orientierung zu
geben und die Richtung ist klar wir
bewältigen die Krise aber wir
vernachlässigen die Zukunftsaufgaben
dieses Landes dabei nicht
ich will das andreaskreten deutlich
machen erstens enthält dieser
Bundeshaushalt für das Jahr 2023 Rekord
Entlastungen in einer Größenordnung wie
sie dieses Land über viele Jahre nicht
gesehen hat neben vielen Maßnahmen zur
Entlastung der Familien und auch
bedürftiger Menschen will ich aus
tagesaktuellen Gründen auf das
inflationsausgleichsgesetz zu sprechen
kommen das ja heute der Bundesrat auch
bestätigt hat im nächsten Jahr werden
wir die arbeitende Bevölkerung die
Steuerzahlerinnen und Steuerzahler
verschonen vor ansonsten drohenden fast
19 Milliarden Euro Steuererhöhungen
heimliche Steuererhöhungen soziale
Gerechtigkeit bemisst sich daran dass
die Menschen die bedürftig sind nicht
alleine gelassen werden aber soziale
Gerechtigkeit hat auch eine andere
Komponente nämlich Fairness gegenüber
denjenigen die mit ihrer Arbeit dieses
Land tragen und hohe Steuern und Abgaben
zahlen
wir werden wir werden liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen für den nächsten Haushalt
2024 davon bin ich überzeugt daran
anknüpfen müssen sie internationale
Umfeld unseres Landes verändert sich
fundamental hier wäre den Inflation
reduction Act der Vereinigten Staaten
und andere Veränderungen unseres Umfelds
wir werden auch neu erkennen müssen dass
das Steuerrecht ein Teil ein Instrument
sein kann um die Standortqualität
unseres Landes insgesamt zu verbessern
und vor allen Dingen die privaten
Investitionen anzuschieben die wir für
die Erneuerung unserer Wirtschaft
brauchen für saubere Technologie und
Digitalisierung
wenn er einen zweiten aspektrekord
Investitionen dieser Bundeshaushalt
umfasst rekordinvestitionen in die
digitale und in die
Verkehrsinfrastruktur in den Klimaschutz
in effiziente Gebäude 50 Milliarden Euro
stehen im Etat zur Verfügung hinzu
kommen die Mittel aus dem
klima-tüchtigung der Bundeswehr haben
wir ein Sonderprogramm von 100
Milliarden Euro aufgelegt Werte
anwesende liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die Herausforderung ist in Deutschland
nicht mehr
öffentliche Mittel bereitzustellen
Kapital bereitzustellen für
Zukunftsaufgaben das hat sich verändert
diese Koalition hat haushaltspolitisch
alle Voraussetzungen geschaffen für die
Gewinnung unserer Zukunft die Aufgabe
liegt jetzt woanders diese Mittel müssen
tatsächlich genutzt werden und dafür
brauchen wir andere schnellere Planungs-
damit das was im Haushalt steht auch
tatsächlich in der Praxis das Leben der
Menschen verbessert
und zum dritten liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen mit diesem Bundeshaushalt
kehren wir zurück zur Schuldenbremse wir
haben ja ich komme jetzt gleich darauf
zurück das wollte ich von mir aus
ansprechen aber es war kein Selbstläufer
dass wir in diesem Bundeshaushalt die
Schuldenbremse einhalten wir mussten
auch
Konsolidierungsanstrengungen Unternehmen
und können gottlob ja auch bestimmte
krisenbedingte Ausgaben jetzt beenden
als ein Beispiel etwa die
corona-test-verordnung bis Ende Februar
des nächsten Jahres finanziert sind noch
einmal für den Dezember Januar und
Februar gut 1,2 Milliarden Euro aber
dann läuft das aus wir wissen noch nicht
genau wie die weitere Entwicklung ist
aber stand jetzt bei den jetzigen
Erwartungen zur Entwicklung der Pandemie
können wir sagen dass mindestens für den
Bundeshaushalt der erste dritte 2023
gewissermaßen der haushaltspolitische
freedom der ist also
Konsolidierungsanstrengungen haben wir
vorgenommen aber dennoch liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sollten wir uns
nicht zu sehr rühmen dass wir die
Schuldenbremse erreicht haben denn wir
werden im nächsten Jahr unverändert
gesamtstaatlich ein enormes Defizit
haben eine Norm ist Defizit deshalb weil
wir für unsere politische Vorhaben in
der Haushaltspolitik des Bundes die
Schuldenbremse beachten und
selbstdisziplinieren dass sie aber
natürlich die krisenbedingten Ausgaben
für Strom und gaspreisbremse in von der
Pandemie bekannten Wirtschaft und
stabilisierungsform bündeln das hat eine
Bank ist nicht nur der Selbstbindung der
Koalition an die Stabilitätspolitik
sondern auch um Flexibilität zu haben
das ist vielen Rednerinnen und Rednern
der Opposition bislang gar nicht
aufgefallen die Strom- und die
gaspreisbremse kann man nicht genau
prognostizieren weil wir die Strom und
die Gaspreise in ihrer Entwicklung des
nächsten Jahres nicht kennen und aus
diesem Grund brauchten wir das
Instrument mit seiner Flexibilität wir
verbinden also die Disziplin für den
Bundeshaushalt mit den notwendigen
Maßnahmen zu Krisen Bewältigung ich
komme zum Schluss liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen nach der Haushaltsberatung ist
vor der Haushaltsberatung der Haushalt
2024 wird ungleich herausfordernder als
der Haushalt des Jahres 2023 um
haushaltswahrheit zu schaffen haben wir
die von der früheren Regierung ja
aufgebauten Rücklagen begonnen
aufzulösen 2024 werden keine mehr zur
Verfügung stehen in nennenswerten Umfang
wir werden diese ambitionsniveau
steigern müssen bei klimainvestitionen
wir werden unser ambitionsniveau
steigern müssen bei der Digitalisierung
und bei der Verbesserung der
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit der deutschen
Wirtschaft der Haushalt 2024 wird noch
herausfordernder als dieser wir haben
also keine Alternative wir müssen weiter
mutig bleiben
Christian Lindner der
Bundesfinanzminister Wilhelm kommenden
Jahr
476,9 Milliarden Euro Ausgaben und
ausgeben und hat fast dreimal so hohe
Kredite wie ursprünglich veranschlagt
nämlich 31 Milliarden mehr als
ursprünglich geplant Stefan Müller jetzt
für die cdu/cs in einer haushaltswoche
dann gerade wenn sie schlussberatung ist
einmal ein Fazit zu ziehen und sich
vielleicht auch ein paar Fragen zu
stellen also ich habe jetzt meine
letzten Tagen zwei Fragen gestellt die
erste Frage ob das wissen wir aber noch
nicht Olaf Scholz vielleicht später noch
kommt und die Kapitänsbinde trägt
die zweite Frage die ich mir gestellt
habe ist
was hätte eigentlich Christian Lindner
als Fraktionsvorsitzender der FDP gesagt
wenn wir in unserer Regierungszeit einen
solchen Haushalt vorgelegt hätten einen
solchen Haushalt vorgelegt hätten der
vorgibt die Schuldenbremse einzuhalten
das aber nur schafft weil sie Geld aus
der Rücklage entnehmen
Ausgaben in Schattenhaushalte verschiebt
und Buchungsregeln verändert was hätte
Christian Lindner gesagt zu unserer
Regierungszeit wenn wir dann auch noch
in unserer Finanzminister sich hier
hingestellt hätte und gesagt hätte
das ist solide das ist seriös das ist
vorausschauend es ist nachhaltig das ist
ein Bild der Spaß am Kalk des in diesem
Haushalt gezeichnet wird und das ganze
ist auch noch
verfassungskonform wir werden es leider
nicht erfahren aber alles das was wir
jetzt gerade hier gehört haben hätte
jedenfalls Christian Lindner zu
seinerzeit zu unserer Regierungszeit
jedenfalls nicht durchgehen lassen
zurecht liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und
ich glaube franz münteferien war es mal
der gesagt hat es ist nicht fair wenn
man nach Wahlen dann auch tatsächlich an
Wahlprogrammen von Vorwahlen auch
tatsächlich erinnert ich will es aber
trotzdem mal tun die FDP das hat er auch
gesagt das stimmt
aber nichtsdestotrotz die FDP hat in
ihrem Wahlprogramm zur Bundestagswahlen
noch versprochen
dabei stehen wir für eine solide und
investitionsorientierte Haushaltspolitik
und zur im Grundgesetz verankerten
Schuldenbremse jede Generation hat ihre
Herausforderungen und muss über die
finanzpolitische Spielräume verfügen um
diesen gerecht zu werden die Realität
sieht aber anders aus die Realität sind
so aus dass seit Beginn ihrer Regierung
sie 545 Milliarden Euro an
kreditkreditermächtungen zulasten des
Haushaltes ausgebracht haben 60
Milliarden beim zweiten
Nachtragshaushalt
2140 Milliarden beim Bundeshaushalt 22
100 Milliarden beim Bundeswehr
Sondervermögen 200 Milliarden beim
Abwehrschirm und 45,6 Milliarden beim
Bundeshaushalt 23 über eine halbe
Millionen Billionen Euro in gerade mal
12 Monaten wenn Sie alle diese
kredichtermächtigungen ausnutzen werden
sie in dieser Wahlperiode mehr Schulden
machen als sechs Bundeskanzler von
Konrad Adenauer bis Helmut Kohl zusammen
wenn Fortschritt für sie bedeutet mal
neue Maßstäbe beim Schulden machen zu
setzen dann haben sie das
etikett-fortschrittskoalition wirklich
verdient liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
von der Ampel das ist jedenfalls
weder generationengerecht noch
nachhaltig und ganz sicher nicht das was
sie vor der Wahl versprochen haben und
übrigens der Bundesrechnungshof ist ja
da auch sehr klar in seinem Urteil in
seinem Bericht vom 18 Oktober zu
finanzieren des abwehrschirms kritisiert
der Bundesrechnungshof unter der
Überschrift
Finanzierung des Schutzschirms
verfassungs- und haushaltsrechtlich
problematisch
und schreibt dann weiter die vorgesehene
Finanzierung des Schutzschirms durch den
wirtschaftsstabilisier ist mit
mehrfacher in sich problematisch die
etatisierung der Mittel in einem
Sondervermögen verstärkt die bereits
bestehende Intransparenz des
bundeshaushaltsplans die vorgesehene
Kreditaufnahme auf Vorrat verstößt gegen
den verfassungsmäßigen Grundsatz der
Jährlichkeit und die Auswirkungen sind
ja schon auch klar zu sehen übrigens
früher konnte man in den Bundeshaushalt
schauen und wusste was und wie viel Geld
und ausgeben wird jetzt muss man noch
etwa 200 Milliarden Sie genau wissen sie
es nicht hinzu addieren um zu wissen wie
viel man will und wie viel der Bund
ausgegeben ich sag gleich gerne noch was
zu Ihnen wenn die Zeit bleibt das
gleiche beide Schulden früher konnte man
in den Bundeshaushalt schauen und wusste
wie viel Geld der Bund sich leiden würde
jetzt muss man noch verschiedene
Sondervermögen hinzu addieren und der
Fricke weil sie da gerade reinrufen es
war ja noch nicht mal möglich für die
haushaltspolitischen Sprecher der Ampel
Koalition genau zu sagen was denn der
Bund im nächsten Jahr ausgeben wird sie
mussten dann also übrigens alles
nachzuschauen Youtube ab Minute 55 sie
haben gesagt wir wissen es nicht so
genau müssten mal nachgucken sie liefern
die Zahlen nach ihr Kindler sagt dann
müssen die Zahlen auch nachliefern wir
wissen es nicht und ich glaube Herr rote
war es dann der am Ende gesagt es tut
uns leid wir sind ja jetzt nach 16
Minuten nach 16 Stunden auch tatsächlich
haushaltsbereinigungssitzungen ich sag
mal das hat mit Müdigkeit das kann man
entschuldigen von mir ist es 18 aber das
kann man entschuldigen am Ende liegt es
doch aber nicht an 18 Stunden
Bereinigung sitzen sondern es liegt an
der Intransparenz ihres Haushaltes dass
sie selbst nicht mehr wissen wie
tatsächlich die Zahlen zustande kommen
und noch nicht einmal mehr einfache
Fragen der antworten können in einer
solchen Bundespressekonferenz also ich
fasse noch mal zusammen die
Schuldenbremse für die sie sich rühmen
in der Bundesfinanzminister wird nur auf
dem Papier eingehalten machen sie den
schaffen es nur mit Entnahmen aus der
Rücklage mit buchungs-
Schlussrunde zum Haushaltsgesetz 2023
nächste Rednerin Wiebke ist da von der
SPD sie ist die Vorsitzende im Gremium
Sondervermögen Bundeswehr 100 Milliarden
von dem ja hier schon mehrfach die Rede
war
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
in Deutschland werden jede Stunde 13
Frauen Opfer der Brutalität ihres
aktuellen oder ehemaligen Partners im
letzten Jahr wurden mehr als 100 Frauen
getötet weil sie eine Frau waren diese
Tötungen tragen einen Namen sie müssen
als das benannt werden was sie sind
femizide und heute ist orange day der
Internationale Tag gegen Gewalt an
Frauen darum tragen viele zumindest der
demokratischen Parteien hier im Haus
auch orangene Kleidungsstücke ich freue
mich über Ihre Krawatte Herr Lindner
interpretäre sie auch nicht als Zufall
sondern als klares Zeichen
und wir tragen heute eben orange um ein
Zeichen zu setzen und wohlig sei es eine
Farbe oder eine kapitänswinde ist
wichtig in der Politik um zu zeigen
wofür wir stehen
aber meine Damen und Herren aber Politik
ist viel mehr und darum sind wir heute
hier zusammengekommen um den Haushalt zu
debattieren und den Haushalt zu
beschließen denn Politik darf nie bei
Empörung enden sie darf nie die Symbolik
einfach nur überholen sondern sie muss
den Zeichen genauso wie den Worten Taten
folgen lassen und das tun wir mit diesem
Haushalt
darum haben wir als Haushälterinnen und
Haushälter in den letzten Monaten
Tabellen studiert wir haben Deckblätter
geschrieben und wir haben übers Geld
verhandeln und wir haben so einige
Akzente gesetzt die auch noch im
parlamentarischen Verfahren in der schon
berühmten angesprochenen
Bereinigungssitzung dazugekommen sind
und ich kann nur ein ganz kleinen
Ausschnitt davon aus aufzählen wir haben
zum Beispiel 700 Millionen Euro
zusätzlich für Fördermaßnahmen im SGB II
bzw jetzt Bürgergeld für die
Unterstützung der Jobcenter zur
Verfügung gestellt neben der Erhöhung
des Kindergeldes auf 250 € die größte
Kindergeld Erhöhung in der Geschichte
der Bundesrepublik haben wir auch beim
Kinderzuschlag noch einmal 400 Millionen
Euro obendrauf gesagt ist und 130
Millionen beim unterhaltsvorschossen wir
haben aufgestockt 2,2 Milliarden Euro
für mehr Wohngeld weil wir mit der
wohngeldreform vor allem auch mehr
Menschen unterstützen wollen wir haben
zwei Milliarden zusätzlich für den
humanitäre Hilfe im weltweiten Kampf
gegen den Hunger zivile
krisenkerventionen und zur Finanzierung
des Resett ein Programm für Menschen in
Gefahr eine aus Afghanistan
bereitgestellt wir haben 500 Millionen
Euro zusätzlich fürs nächste Jahr für
den Schienenverkehr bewilligt und 700
Millionen Euro für zusätzliche
Investitionsvorhaben in den Kommunen vor
Ort beispielsweise um Schwimmbäder oder
Turnhallen zu sanieren oder die
Anpassung an den Klimawandel ganz
konkret vor Ort zusammen
voranzubringen wir haben einen
Pilotprojekt 100 Millionen Euro für den
Kulturpass für junge Menschen für all
diejenigen die 18 werden im nächsten
Jahr die damit kostenlos dann in Museen
ins Theater aber auch um Bücher zu
kaufen das einsetzen können wir haben
7,5 Millionen fürs nächste Jahr und dann
Verpflichtungsermächtigung von 60
Millionen Euro für die Grace
satelliten-mission eine der wichtigen
Forschungsvorhaben für den Klimawandel
bereitgestellt
und da kann ich jetzt noch weitermachen
und weitermachen Helge Braun hat ganz
ausführlich auch dargestellt wie viele
Änderungsanträge wir gehackt haben
[Musik]
ich will aber eine Frage auch noch
beantworten und zwar die was tun wir
denn jetzt gegen Gewalt an Frauen nicht
nur die Symbolik sondern eben auch die
Taten und auch hier will ich nur drei
Beispiele rausgreifen es gibt letztlich
auch viel mehr im Haushalt des
Innenministeriums wird das Projekt
gewaltfrei in die Zukunft finanziert im
Rahmen dessen wird eine tarn-app
entwickelt die es ermöglicht Frauen vor
allem Frauen aber alle die von
häuslicher Gewalt betroffen sind zu
dokumentieren verschlüsselt und rechts
sicher zu speichern welche Verletzungen
sie erlitten haben um die
Strafverfolgung nachher besser umsetzen
zu können im Einzelplan des
Familienministeriums werden Projekte zur
Erprobung von geeigneten Maßnahmen zur
Gewaltprävention im Bereich auch
Sexismus für medizide aber auch digitale
Wald gefördert z.B die
Bundesarbeitsgemeinschaft Täter Arbeit
häusliche Gewalt und Imitat des
Justizministeriums und weil gerade auch
Frauen online durch hassposts und von
psychischer Gewalt betroffen sind haben
hier im parlamentarischen Verfahren
beschlossen die Arbeit der
Beratungsstelle hate8 mit 500.000 Euro
zu unterstützen
und an Sie liebe Bundesregierung wenn
wir als Haushälterinnen und Haushälter
immer zurecht wieder zur Sparsamkeit
mahnen dann seien sie als Mitglieder der
Bundesregierung gewiss auch wenn die
Symbolik auf das kostengünstigste Art
oder die kostengünstigste Mittel der
Politik ist dann wollen wir taten sehen
wollen taten die ganz konkret etwas
bewirken und wir wissen auch dass die
fast immer etwas kosten und in diesem
Sinne bedanke ich mich für die gute
Zusammenarbeit mit den Ministerien werbe
für den Haushalt der ein guter geworden
ist stimmen Sie den gleich zu danke
schön
das Wort hat der Abgeordneten Norbert
Kleinwächter für die afd-fraktion
werte Frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen bedenklich
viele Kollegen haben die Krise in dieser
haushaltswoche als Chance bezeichnet
oder Scholz sowieso Friedrich merzer
eine Chance Besitztümer besitzt Stände
auf die Probe zu stellen
Andreas Schwarz redete davon dass es
eine Gelegenheit gäbe große Dinge zu tun
und ich weiß sie träumen alle von der
sozialen ökologischen Transformation vom
radikalen Umbau der Gesellschaft auf
deren Ruinen sie ihre klimaneutrale
Domus Aurea entwickeln wollen wo dann
Windräder und Bakterien Stahl
produzieren aber ich habe eine schlechte
Nachricht für Sie Krise bedeutet eben
nicht automatisch Chance sondern
ethomologisch erstmal ein Wort seine
Entscheidung und von der Entscheidung
hängt es ab ob eine Chance erfolgt oder
der Niedergang die Ängste Verwandte der
Krise das ist die Katastrophe und ihre
Politik ist wahrlich katastrophal
sie treffen eine verheerende
Entscheidung nach der anderen sie senden
Unternehmen und Bürger in existenzielle
Nöte und alles was sie dann tun ist
Milliarden und aber Milliarden Schulden
aufzunehmen um das irgendwie zuzudecken
sie besaufen sich dermaßen Schulden dass
sie in der Hand Schulden das sind doch
die nächsten Jahrzehnte ausnüchtern
müssen Herr Lindner und wo wir schon bei
deinen Nachhaltigkeit sind Frau Werbung
sie reden immer von Nachhaltigkeit
finanzielle Nachhaltigkeit bedeutet
Spielräume und Freiheit für die Zukunft
zu belassen und nicht unsere Kinder und
Enkel noch auf Jahrzehnte einzuhängen
dass sie das wissen müssen dass sie hier
für ideologische Projekte aufnehmen und
das verschieben Sie ein
Schattenhaushalte in Sondervermögen und
nicht darüber zu sprechen und das ist
genauso ein Pharisäertum wir dass er
sich hier gerade machen hier im Plenum
mit ihren orangenen Anzügen mit ihrer
orangenen Krawatte Herr Lindner ja es
ist orange da ist sie demonstrieren
damit sie sind gegen Gewalt gegen Frauen
aber vielleicht sollte man nicht im
gleichen Atemzug den Frauenhäusern 10
Millionen Euro entziehen in diesem
Bundeshaushalt damit sie den äh der
anti-deutschen kann man sagen
250% anwachsen lassen das ist wahrlich
heuchlerisch
aber es ist ja interessant es ist
interessant für Sie zu Deutschland sehen
und man sieht es an der Rede von Olaf
Scholz der der verwendet Deutschland nie
als Subjekt immer nur als Objekt oder
als Attribut irgendwo und vor allem
redet er erstmal über Deutschlands
Abhängigkeit die verschlimmern sie
wahrlich mit ihrer Schuldenpolitik und
dann spricht davon Deutschland als Land
der Funklöcher und Schlaglöcher der
kaputten Brücken und verspäteten Züge da
sagt ich nur das kommt dabei raus wenn
man immer in die Ferne kommt statt aus
eigener Land und statt auf die eigene
Leute 21,3 Milliarden den Euro war die
nettozahlung an der europäischen an die
europäischen Union im Jahr 2021 15 Mal
so viel wieder Beitrag der drittgrößten
Volkswirtschaft Italiens gerade eine
gute Milliarde hat uns gefehlt dann
hätten wir mehr bezahlt als alle anderen
Nettozahler zusammen dazu kommen noch 66
Milliarden letzte Generation you plus
Inflation die ganze Entwicklungshilfe
die Klima aus dem Projekte alles
mögliche ich sage Ihnen was ihre Politik
ist auf die Ware Krise meine Damen und
Herren und die beste Entscheidung wäre
die Entscheidungsgewalt dieser
Bundesregierung baldmöglichst zu beenden
haben sie vielen Dank
[Applaus]
muss bloß mal organisatorisch schauen
Frau Mast
genau also zu einer Kurzintervention hat
die Abgeordnete Master
parlamentarische geschäftsführende SPD
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin
ich will an dieser Stelle festhalten
dass die SPD-Bundestagsfraktion und ich
bin mir sicher dass ich auch im Namen
der ganzen Ampel spreche
ausdrücklich die Arbeit von
förderattermann als
antidiskriminierungsbeauftragte des
Deutschen Bundestags ist demokratische
gewählt worden in voller Wertschätzung
Schätze und ich gut finde dass wir sie
als
antidiskriminierungsbeauftragte für die
Bundesrepublik Deutschland gewinnen
konnten und ich ausdrücklich Hass und
Hetze von meinem Vorredner zurückweisen
möchte
sie haben das Wort zur Erwiderung werte
Frau Präsidentin werte Frau Mast diese
Wertschätzung haben sie durchaus zum
Ausdruck gebrachten wir würden
wertschätzen wenn man die Frauen
tatsächlich vor Gewalt schützen würde
und ich darf gerne noch mal ausführen
was ich hier im Antrag der AG Haushalt
der Fraktionen SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen
und FDP von
18.10.2022 im Haushaltsausschuss
durchgesetzt haben es geht um Kapitel
1703 Titel
89323-290 Bundesprogramm zur Förderung
von Innovationen im Hilfesystem zur
Unterstützung Gewalt betroffener Frauen
mit ihren Kindern Baum Modernisierung
und Sanierung um zehn Millionen Euro
reduziert und ich frage mich schon meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren was
dieses Symbol Politik soll ich hier eben
auch angesprochen habe einer
Kapitänsbinde one dir gleich hier in
orange rumlaufen und den Frauen die
wirklich auf Hilfe angewiesen sind
die Frauenhäuser dafür zuständig sind
die Mittel zu entziehen damit Sie sich
schützen können sie behaupten sie stehen
für Menschen für Frauen für
diskriminierte Menschen ein in Wahrheit
betreiben sie eine Schuldenpolitik die
sie verschleiern Sie Beat betreiben eine
Politik gegen die Interessen
Deutschlands und wer darauf hinweist den
den beleidigen sie als Hetzer den
beleidigen sie als jemand der
diskriminieren würde der hier austeilt
ich sage Ihnen mal ganz ehrlich meine
Damen und Herren
da im Interesse Deutschlands ist es
tatsächlich auf die eigenen Leute zu
achten die Bevölkerung zu schützen
unsere Industrie zu schützen unsere
Menschen in unserem Land zu schützen und
in ihrem Bundeshaushalt den Sie hier
vorgelegt haben da ist absolut nichts
davon zu sehen genauso wenig wie in den
Intentionen einer förder-attermann die
deutsche Mann als Kartoffel und
spargelfresser bezeichnet hat danke
schön für dieses Buch
wir fahren in der Debatte fort
das Wort hat der Kollege Markus Kurt für
die Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
frau Präsidentin sehr verehrte Damen und
Herren Herr Kleinwächter ich weiß ja
nicht was sie nehmen ich sag nur nehmen
sie weniger davon
und ich sage Ihnen auch ich sage Ihnen
auch
was es mit den Mitteln die sie wo sie
unterstellen dass wir sie kürzen was
passiert ist wir haben weil die Mittel
im Moment nicht abfließen in dem Bereich
der Frauenhäuser sie in die Zukunft
verschoben haben ein entsprechenden
Antrag gemacht und das die Kürzung ist
nicht Erfolg das ist erstmal die
Wahrheit
so und nachdem wir das jetzt hinter uns
haben will ich sagen dass wirklich die
Verhandlungen geprägt hat dass wir
mehrere Herausforderungen haben wir
haben ja diese Krisen auf die wir
reagieren müssen und es sind nicht nur
multiple Krisen sondern auch von
unterschiedlichen Charakter werden den
Klimawandel als Dauerkrise und den Krieg
in der Ukraine als disruptive Krise die
wirklich Struktur Brüche und nicht nur
Strukturwandel verursacht wir müssen
gleichzeitig zweitens ein
Reparaturbetrieb nach wie vor Betreiben
von Dingen die unterlassen wurden in den
vergangenen Jahren und
Legislaturperioden kommt man nicht umhin
zu sagen und das wird uns auch noch
nachhängen in den nächsten Jahren und
wir müssen Zukunft Gestaltung trotz
alledem betreiben und dieses alles
zusammengenommen ist glaube ich mit
diesem Haushalt bei allen
Schwierigkeiten und auch gelegentlichen
Unwuchten die es gibt und auch bei allem
ganz normalen politischen Streit den es
zum Teil auch innerhalb der Koalition
gibt das ist demokratische Kultur wenn
das zivilisiert abläuft das ist uns
glaube ich unter dem Strich gut gelungen
aber wir können natürlich feststellen
dass es auch eine eigentümliche
Gleichzeitigkeit gibt von
Geschwindigkeit auf der einen Seite
besonders bei krisenreaktionen und einer
gewissen Langsamkeit wenn es um das in
Gang bringen von Strukturveränderungen
geht wir haben das ist ja heute
Vormittag und in der ganzen Woche
mehrfach gesagt worden im gesamten
Bereich der
gasversorgungsinfrastruktur ein paar
Forstwirt hingelegt wir haben die
energiepreispauschalen und
Entlastungsmaßnahmen der
unterschiedlichsten Formen wir haben
internationale krisenreaktionen und
dafür
verehrter Stefan Müller braucht man auch
diese 200 Milliarden Euro im WSF wenn
man die beklagt und gleichzeitig keine
eigenen Vorschläge unterbreitet muss man
doch trotzdem irgendwie die Antwort
geben und das fehlt von ihrer Seite wie
man schnelle wirksame Krisenintervention
hinkriegt
und auf der anderen Seite auf der
anderen Seite ist auch deutlich geworden
welche Schwierigkeiten da insgesamt noch
vor uns stehen könnten Sie vielleicht
ein bisschen leiser da hinten
diskutieren danke so
ich erinnere mich sehr gut an
die Befragung und Auseinandersetzungen
mit Volker Wissing im
Haushaltsausschuss der uns da auch sehr
detailliert dargelegt hat wo Hemmnisse
sind und wo zum Teil auch wir haben ja
mehr Mittel in dem schienenbereich aber
wo wir zum Teil auch einfach an Grenzen
stoßen weil einfach viel zu lange viel
zu viel gerade im Bereich der
Verkehrsinfrastruktur liegen geblieben
ist und man kann natürlich auch andere
Bereiche nennen und Haushalt tierischer
Ausdruck davon ist ja dann der
Mittelabfluss zum Teil Christian Lindner
hat ja völlig zu Recht gesagt haben
Haushalt tierisch jetzt die
Voraussetzungen geschaffen für eine
große Beschleunigung aber es ist glaube
ich auch innerhalb der Beratung schon
deutlich geworden dass
politikprozesscharakter hat und das ist
länger dauert das ist nicht mit einem
Ruck und einem Schlag getan ist und
darum kann ich auch wenig mit diesen
plakativen Äußerungen anfangen von
Friedrich Merz dass er sagt wir brauchen
jetzt die große Rede den großen Wurf
sondern ich glaube es wird speziell bei
der Arbeit im Haushaltsausschuss wird
sehr klar dass wir es mit Prozessen zu
tun haben die wir beschleunigen können
die wir aber nicht über Nacht beliebig
Umsteuern können und darum finde ich ist
es unsere Aufgabe auch gerade als
Haushälter das jetzt mal ganz
grundsätzlich abseits der
tagespolitischen Auseinandersetzungen
gesagt dass wir sparsam umgehen mit
Begriffen wie Bazooka und jetzt muss ein
Ruck rumgehen und auch ehrlich gesagt
mit Doppel Wumms und dergleichen kann
ich nicht so viel anfangen diese jetzt
geht's aber los Mentalität
[Applaus]
Menschen von der Union diese jetzt geht
es aber mal los Mentalität erinnert mich
so ein bisschen an diejenigen Leute die
man Anfang Januar im Fitnessstudio
trifft wo dann auch alles sagen jetzt
wird es aber alles anders im März lehrt
sich das dann meistens dann im Studio
wird das schon etwas weniger mir ist
klar man muss natürlich auch nach außen
sozusagen Handlungsfähigkeit auch verbal
vermitteln aber wir im
Haushaltsausschuss sind diejenigen die
diesen Prozess zu allen Charakter von
Politik auf die Straße bringen und
umsetzen und das ist der Ampel dieses
Mal wieder sehr gut gelungen und in dem
Sinne übernehmen wir jetzt die
kapitänsbinden
ja Markus Kurt quasi durchaus auch eine
Quitte mit Kritik am Bundeskanzler denn
jetzt geht's los der doppelwumms das
sind alles Äußerungen des Bundeskanzlers
Christian Görke jetzt Sprecher für
Finanzpolitik von der Linksfraktion
ihre
Rechte und dazu gehört
Zwischenrufen und sonstigen
verbalen und nonverbalen Äußerungen
seine Gefühle ausdrückt bitte ich
trotzdem um Mäßigung und es gibt keine
Gründe
Konkurrenten und Konkurrenten mit als
Verbrecher zu bezeichnen oder anderes
ich denke man kann auch anders damit
entsprechend in der Debatte umgehen ich
ahne wer diese Zwischenruf getätigt hat
da aber die stehen nur Grafen sie nicht
genau identifizieren konnten muss ich
das jetzt hier in dieser Allgemeinheit
so festhalten
so wir fahren jetzt aber erstmal in der
Debatte fort Christian Görke hat nun für
die Linke das Wort
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ich weiß ja nicht wie es Ihnen
geht aber mein Gefühl ist dass dieser
Finanzminister eigentlich ein
Doppelleben führt mal ist er ja
Ideologie Gesellschaft ftp-chef dann ist
der Realpolitik je nach Wetterlage da
draußen das Problem ist am Ende kommt
immer schlechte Politik raus erst kann
er die übergewinne in Deutschland bei
dem Mineralölkonzern nicht sehen dann
macht die EU-Kommission natürlich sehend
und trotzdem laufen möglicherweise
nächste Freitag die exorbitanten über
Gewinne nahezu unbesteuert durch und das
meine Damen und Herren und deshalb
richte ich meine Hoffnung an die FDS
waren die Grünen und die SPD dass sie
diese steuerpolitisches Skandal in einer
Gebieten weiter geht's dann wenn einem
Interview von Christian lindern Spiegel
ich zitiere den Satz es ist ein
Irrglaube wir könnten die Inflation mit
zusätzlichen Schulen in den Griff
bekommen eine Woche später
präsentieren Sie uns in doppelwumms 200
Milliarden Euro Schulden und natürlich
helfen die die Preise zu senken wie
passt das zusammen im Mai fordert er
dann die EZB öffentlich auf doch endlich
die Zinsen zu erhöhen heute sind die
Zinsen höher und sie stellen sich
wirklich letzten Dienstag hierhin und
präsentieren sie als Opfer der
Zinspolitik weil im Haushalt jetzt mehr
als 30 Milliarden Euro anzünden drauf
geht also meine Damen und Herren Unglaub
würde ja geht es nicht und eins noch
Steuererhöhungen für Topverdiener lehnen
sie ja ab weil sie hat viel schlecht
sind für die Wirtschaft nach ihrer Sicht
gleichzeitig kürzen Sie aber die
Zuschüsse bei den Krankenkassen und
lassen die Zusatzbeiträge für 70
Millionen
Versicherte steigen und dem Dax Manager
und denen die viel Geld haben da sagt
nur bei das Bemessungsgrenze bei denen
ist das Penken aber bei der kassieren
zum Beispiel beim wahlkreisender Lausitz
ist das schmerzlich und deshalb kommen
wir zum Schluss vor Präsidentin Herr
Minister beenden sie endlich ihr doppelt
Leben machen sie mal Politik für die
kassieren statt mit ihrer
stellvertretenden Kapitänsbinde sich
hier als Bodyguard der Reichen und
Vermögen in diesem Land vielen Dank
der nächste Redner hier in der
Schlussrunde zum Haushaltsgesetz
2023 ist Otto Fricke der
haushaltspolitische Sprecher der FDP
Bundestagsfraktion
in Brandenburg nicht mehr zur
stellvertretenden Kapitänsbinde gereicht
hat ist mir nach der Rede jetzt
inzwischen auch ganz klar ich will aber
doch deutlich ich werde aber deutlich
ihnen eines noch klar machen sie haben
Haushalt überhaupt nicht verstanden es
war genauso wenig wie die CDU das haben
wir beim Kollegen Müller gemerkt aber
nein die CSU will ich nicht noch weiter
in die Tiefe ziehen das muss nicht sein
Herr Kollege aber Sie müssen doch eines
sehen was ist die Aufgabe eines solchen
Haushaltes in einer Übergangszeit in
einer Zeiten wenn wir diese
Übergangszeit zu organisieren und das
hat diese Ampelkoalition in harten
Beratung geschafft und ich möchte neben
dem Dank an den Ausschuss mich auch noch
mal ausdrücklich bei Sven Christian
Kindler und auch wenn das nicht gerne
hört in Abwesenheit an der bei Dennis
Rode bedanken und ihren jeweiligen Teams
wir haben da viel diskutiert gemeinsam
mit den AGs aber wir haben Ende genau
das geschafft was scheinbar weder auf
der linken Seite noch bei der CDU
geschweige denn bei der CSU funktioniert
die haben Demokratie gearbeitet und sind
zu einem sehr guten Ergebnis mit diesem
Haushalt gekommen
meine Damen und Herren hätte mir jemand
am Anfang der Haushaltsdebatten gesagt
dass wir in das nächste Jahr gehen mit
enormen Steuersenkungen mit dem
Einhalten der Schuldenbremse aber
gleichzeitig mit einer Absicherung im
Bereich Energie im Bereich Strom einer
Absicherung im Bereich Verteidigung dass
die ausreichenden Mittel dagewesenheit
gesagt das weiß ich nicht ob wir das
alles schaffen wir haben das geschafft
und vielleicht Kollege Müller weil das
für mich die größte Enttäuschung der
Haushaltsberatung war nämlich das
Verhalten der cdu/csu das erste ist was
sie nicht verstanden haben beim Haushalt
ein Haushalt ist im Rahmen der
Gewaltenteilung die ist in dieser
Koalition gibt eine Ermächtigung der
Regierung Geld auszugeben es ist aber
nicht die Verpflichtung für alles und
jedes Geld auszugeben wenn sie erkennt
dass man es nicht mehr braucht und
deswegen wenn sie behaupten dass jemand
wissen müsste wie viel Schulden im
nächsten Jahr gemacht werden zeigt das
nur eines sie haben Haushalt nicht
verstanden sie haben Haushaltspolitik
nicht verstanden und sie haben ihre
Oppositionsrolle überhaupt nicht
verstanden das ist ihr großes Problem
sie streiten sich ja jetzt schon darüber
ich habe das ja heute im Pioneer gelesen
wer den jetzt bei der cdu/csu kannst
dann Kandidat wird um die Kapitänsbinde
da dann mal zu bekommen ehrlich sage ich
ihnen lassen sich noch sechs sieben
Jahre Zeit dann wird das vielleicht
meine Frage sein die Sie sich stellen
können mich erinnert das inzwischen weil
ich ja Shakes bin ich immer zitieren
darf an Theodor Fontane sondern Mehnert
ja der Zukunft wächst die qualmbrücke
steht der Captain nach dem Steuer spät
er sieht nach seinem Steuermann aber
durch spracherfragt er an verdammt noch
mal Liebe cducsu macht doch mal endlich
Haushaltspolitik die ehrlich ist und das
will ich dann noch an einem Beispiel an
einem Beispiel Ihnen sagen wir haben
gestern als letzte Debatte den 1-23
Bildung Forschung gehabt da redet als
erstes die von mir sehr geschätzte
Kollegin radomsky und erklärt wie man es
anders machen könnte wo mehr wo weniger
wo einsparen wo anders ausgehen soweit
gut danach kommt dann die zuständige
stellvertretende fraktionszeit das ist
alles zu wenig da müssen mehr Milliarden
rausgehauen werden warum tut er das
nicht heute Bereich Wirtschaft auch
wieder ja nur noch und ich sage das ganz
deutlich Frau Karliczek da muss im
Haushalt mit Schmackes mehr Geld
ausgegeben werden das seid ihr doch das
ist doch die Opposition mit der wir es
zu tun haben und ich sag mal so
vielleicht haben es auch deswegen so gut
hingekriegt weil wir auf die Opposition
gar nicht groß achten muss zum Schluss
der Ausblick und da gucke ich mir dann
die Regierungsbank schon ein bisschen
genauer an ich will das deutlich sagen
erstens die andere Bank die auch heute
wieder leer ist mit der muss sich nach
meiner Meinung die Bundesregierung auch
im Rahmen des Eckwerte Verfahrens mehr
auseinandersetzen denn was wir erleben
ist doch inzwischen immer mehr wir
versuchen vernünftig ein Haushalt zu
planen auf Bundesebene egal übrigens das
waren letzten Legislatur auch schon so
und dann kommen die Länder machen an der
Stelle Vereinbarungen die zulassen des
Bundes gehen und wir müssen dann gucken
wie wir das im Haushalt alles noch
darstellen deswegen meine Bitte bei dem
aufstehende Eckwerte auf den Bundesrat
achten zweitens die Investition ich sage
das hier nochmal deutlich schon getan
aber Deutschland daran denken auch wenn
die Staatsquote 50 Prozent ist die
Investitionsquote ist ein Verhältnis von
8 privat zu Einstand wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass private investieren und nur
dann wenn wir das schaffen werden wir
vernünftige Eckwerte hinbekommen werden
wir auch einen vernünftigen Haushalt
2024 hinbekommen dieser jedenfalls ist
gut und gut verhandelt ich danke
Otto Fricke hat sicherlich nicht so
gemeint die bundesratsbank ist heute
natürlich deshalb leer weil parallel der
Bundesrat tagt und der hat im übrigen
jetzt auch schon das Bürgergeld
durchgewunken damit kann es zum ersten
Januar in Kraft treten wir werden im
Anschluss an diese Übertragung Ihnen die
Debatte im deutschen Bundesrat
nachtragen Christian Hasi jetzt für die
CDU Mitarbeiter die uns während der
Haushaltsberatung seitens das
Haushaltsausschusses begleitet haben in
Mitarbeitern in den unseren Büros die
viel Arbeit uns auch abgenommen haben in
der Vorbereitung und natürlich den AG
Mitarbeitern aus unserer Fraktion der
danke gilt natürlich auch an alle
Kolleginnen und Kollegen aus dem
Haushaltsausschuss insbesondere unseren
Vorsitzenden Helge braun
ich möchte in dieser Schlussrunde nicht
mit einzelnen Anträgen rumwedeln und es
geht mir ausdrücklich auch nicht um die
aktuelle Krisenhilfe ich möchte dass wir
zum Schluss auch noch mal über die
großen Linien diskutieren denn ich
glaube in unserem Land läuft etwas
schief die fetten Jahre sind vorbei die
mögen die meisten in diesem Haus ja noch
zustimmen aber solche Konsequenzen
ziehen wir denn da raus da Kanzler redet
von Führungen und zeitenwände aber diese
Regierung führt Deutschland nicht als
Anführer aufs Feld da trägt niemand eine
Kapitänsbinde wenn diese Regierung etwas
trägt meine Damen und Herren dann ist es
eine Augenbinde
das Momentum im Frühjahr dieses Land in
eine neue Zeit zu führen wurde verpennt
so hatte es Friedrich Merz in der
Generaldebatte richtigerweise kritisiert
unser Land muss die Augenbinde endlich
ablegen und aus dem Dornröschenschlaf
erwachen es treibt mich um ganz
persönlich um dass wir Deutschen eine
vollkasko-italität entwickelt haben die
sozialstaatsquote hat sich seit den
wirtschaftswunderzeiten fast verdoppelt
zwei Drittel der Deutschen Antwort auf
die Frage wer die Kosten der hohen
Inflation tragen soll der Staat diese
Anspruchshaltung erleben wir nicht nur
bei Verbrauchern sondern mittlerweile
auch bei Unternehmen immer mehr
Zuwendungsempfänger hängen vom Geld des
Bundesamt sind denn Eigenverantwortung
und Selbsthilfe ein Relikt aus
vergangenen Zeiten soll sich der Staat
denn hier um alles kümmern müssen
wenn der Staat uns dann auch noch das
Denken abnimmt dann nenne ich das
Sozialismus und nicht mehr soziale
Marktwirtschaft
aber liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
diese Mentalität ist uns nicht angeboren
sie ist das Ergebnis einer langen
wirtschaftlichen erfolgsphase und der
Illusion der staatlöse Krisen und
Herausforderungen zum Nulltarif und das
sage ich auch ein Stück weit mit
Selbstkritik an meiner Partei was beim
Aufbau Ost und der Finanzkrise 2009 noch
gelungen ist ist bei der Energiewende
Gründe gründlich gescheitert
kritinskugel Eis ist leider längst in
der Sonne geschmolzen und die Ampel
heizt diese Entwicklung weiter an
anstatt sie zu stoppen junge never walk
alone und doppelwumms sind das Motto das
Bürgergeld signalisiert allein
sprachlich dass man sich ums Geld
erstmal keine Sorgen machen muss der
ÖPNV soll möglichst kostenlos werden und
dem Energieministerium erleben wir
planen Wirtschaft
die SPD und Grüne reiten voran und für
die FDP bleibt leider nur die Rolle des
steigbügelhalters
Olaf gersemann schreibt dazu in einem
Artikel der Welt ich zitiere noch
gravierender aber ist wohl die
fiskalische omnipotenzillosion die die
ampelfraktion eifrig blank poliert wenn
ein never alone ein unterhaken
versprochen wird der geht im Zweifel
erst gar nicht selbstlos die Erwartung
des vollkaskoschutzes in
Katastrophenfällen aller Art kann nicht
anders als lebend wirken Zitat Ende
diese Lähmung gilt in zweierlei Hinsicht
zunächst lebt dieses Vorgehen die
innovations- und Leistungsbereitschaft
in unserer Gesellschaft die Folgen der
deutschen Einheit und der Finanzkrise
haben wir nur dadurch überwunden weil
Wirtschaftswachstum und fast
Vollbeschäftigung die nötigen Steuern
gebracht haben und die zweite Gefahr
sind die sich anhäufenden Schuldenberge
nicht umsonst heißt es die Schulden von
heute sind die Steuern von morgen und
dabei sind wir schon jetzt ein
hochsteuerland
meine Damen und Herren die Leute die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in unserem Land
sind da viel weiter als wir glauben sie
spüren dass wir hier überziehen sie
machen sich Sorgen wenn wir in die
Schulden alle bezahlen wollen sie wollen
keinen Staat der alles bestimmt sie
spüren dass es wieder Zeiten gibt indem
wir uns alle anstrengen müssen alle
wirklich alle in diesem Land und deshalb
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Ampel
appelliere ich an sie wecken Sie die
Wachstumskräfte in diesem Land anstatt
sich ständig mit vollkasko-ideen mit
neuer Bürokratie und steuervisionen zu
verhindern hören Sie an dieser Stelle
öfter mal auf ihren Finanzministern
lassen sich Forschung und Gründergeist
zu anstatt Ergebnisse politisch
vorzugeben stärken sie europäische und
in Deutschland die Schuldenbremse
Anstand dauernd zu überlegen wie man sie
umgehen kann deutschland kann mehr man
muss es nur wollen
für die SPD-Fraktion hat nun der Kollege
Andreas Schwarz das
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren fragt man
hier in den Raum was ist das Wichtigste
an deiner Arbeit hier glaube ich dann
sollte die Antworten nicht schwer sein
das wichtigste ist zum Wohle der
Menschen diesem Land beitragen zu können
denn frei nach Helmut Schmidt Politik
ist nicht nur Denksport sondern Politik
ist auch handeln und sehr oft musste
diese Koalition in diesem Jahr
entscheiden und handeln das hätte sich
Olaf Scholz bestimmt auch anders
vorgestellt als in der Bundestag vor
knapp einem Jahr die Kapitänsbinde
angelegt hat liebe Mitbürgerinnen und
Mitbürger persönlich gehe ich gerne mit
meiner kleinen Tochter einkaufen und
schauen wir doch mal gemeinsam ins Land
und vor allen Dingen die Regale die
Preise im Supermarkt an den Tankstellen
im Einzelhandel
sind auf einem sehr hohen Niveau die
Energiekosten sind nach wie vor
beängstigend das sind Kosten meine Damen
und Herren die viele Menschen in unserem
Land nur schwerlich gestemmt bekommen
das macht mir Sorge diese Sorge muss
aber auch Anspruch sein den betroffenen
Menschen und auch vor allen Dingen
unseren Unternehmen umfassend zu helfen
um die schwersten Belastungen dieser
außergewöhnlichen Zeit abzufedern
Wirtschaft Arbeitsmarkt und Gesellschaft
müssen zusammengehalten und stabilisiert
werden und genau das tut diese Koalition
gerade jetzt in der Zeit nicht nur dass
wir einen Haushalt heute verabschieden
der für soziale Gerechtigkeit
klimaschutzfreiheit in der Zeitenwende
steht diese Haushalt lässt auch viel
Luft für Unterstützungsleistungen die
auch nächstes Jahr und umgänglich werden
meine Damen und Herren der
Bundeshaushalt 2023 mal im
Schnelldurchlauf 18 Stunden
schlussberatung mitbekommen über 1000
Anträge in der Sitzung gestellt
Dankeschön an das ausschusssekretariat
an alle die damit geholfen mitgearbeitet
haben
476 Milliarden Euro Gesamtvolumen
ein Jaden Euro nochmal mehr als im
Regierungsentwurf die Schuldenbremse
wurde eingehalten und was uns wichtig
war eine klare parlamentarische
Handschrift in diesem Bundeshaushalt und
meine Damen und Herren auch klare
Prioritäten und ich verrate hier keine
Geheimnisse dieser Bundeshaushalt
entlastet die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
dieser Bundeshaushalt übernimmt
internationale Verantwortung die auch
von uns eingefordert wird wir treiben
den Klimaschutz voran und wir schaffen
rekordinvestitionen von über 71
Milliarden Euro und damit zeigen wir den
Menschen Zukunft und Perspektive auf
unsere Zeit braucht einen starken und
leistungsfähigen Staat Zuverlässigkeit
und Fortschritt sind die Voraussetzungen
um Fortschritte und Zukunft zu
garantieren deswegen investieren wir
Bildung Digitalisierung Klimaschutz
innovative Technologien massiv in
Schiene Transformation aber auch in den
Sozialstaat liebe Bürgerinnen und Bürger
umfassende entlastungspake wird von 300
Milliarden Euro wurden und werden auf
den Weg gebracht überdies gibt es die
Einführung des Bürgergeldes
heizkostenhilfen eine wohngeldreform das
49 Euro Ticket 250 Euro Kindergeld ein
Rekord was hier geleistet wurde
weiterhin profitieren 48 Millionen
Menschen davon dass wir Anpassungen
Steuertarif geschafft haben nicht
vergessen möchte ich aber auch die
Investitionen in unsere Sicherheit über
58 Milliarden Euro für unsere
parlamentarmee um Landes- und
Bündnisverpflichtungen gerecht zu werden
und unsere Bürgerinnen und Bürger
Freiheit und Demokratie gewährleisten zu
können ja die Herausforderungen und da
gebe ich unseren Finanzminister
ausdrücklich Recht die eigentliche
Herausforderung und das Zauberwort heißt
Umsetzung und da sind vor allen Dingen
die Ministerien die Behörden die
ausführenden Organe gefordert und machen
uns nichts vor wir werden da auch
umdenken müssen um schneller zu werden
Deutschland und das ist die klare bot
möglich ist finanziell stark dieses Land
ist kreativ und wir sind innovativ
nutzen wir diese Kraft die in dem Land
schlummert und organisieren wir den
Zusammenhalt in der Zeitenwende diese
Haushalt erfüllt die zeitenwände mit
Leben und er macht vor allen Dingen eins
Freude auf die Zukunft und ich komme ja
aus Franken des höchste Lob was man hier
geben kann dem Finanzminister ist ein
fränkisches passt schon und das ist also
das höchste Lob oder wenn man das mit
den Worten von Helmut Schmidt ausdrücken
möchte diese Haushalt hat Mut zur
Zukunft und abschließend und Olaf Scholz
trägt die Kapitänsbinde für unsere
Regierungsmannschaft zu recht herzlichen
Dank
Andreas Schwarz war das aus der
SPD-Fraktion in der Schlussrunde zum
Haushaltsgesetz 2023 der gesamte
Haushalt von
476 Milliarden Euro wird ja in ein
Gesetz gegossen und dazu jetzt auch noch
mal der Haushälter der Fraktion Bündnis
90 die Grünen Sven Christian Kindler
ich möchte mich auch ganz herzlich am
Anfang beim Ausschussvorsitzenden
bedanken der mit trockenen Humor und
auch mit Schnelligkeit durch die Sitzung
geführt hat an ihm lag es nicht dass wir
80 Stunden gebraucht haben sondern es
waren sehr viele Anträge von
Oppositionen Koalition alleine 526
Anträge haben wir in diesem
Haushaltsverfahren als Koalition
gestellt 420 haben wir insgesamt einen
Bereinigung gestellt
und ich möchte mich insgesamt auch noch
mal bei den Teams der Fraktionen
bedanken meine Mitarbeiter Mitarbeiter
insbesondere auch beim autosekretariat
das ganz hinten hier bei der
bundesratsbank sitzt wir haben ja wir
werden in großen Milliarden Betrag an
die Bundesländer auch in diesem
Bundeshaushalt bereitstellen mich
wundert dass niemand auf der
bundesratsbank kriegt aber ich hoffe
damit umso mehr dass das Auto ist vielen
vielen Dank für ihre Arbeit
und ich möchte mich ganz herzlich noch
mal bedanken bei den
koalitionsarbeitsgruppen Haushalt von
SPD FDP und Grünen insbesondere bei
meinen sprecherkollegen Otto Fricke und
Dennis Rohde der da der
krankheitsbedingt in Ammerland gibt
vielen Dank wir hatten eine intensive
auch harte Verhandlungen und
Diskussionen haben gerungen um die beste
Lösung aber es war immer sachbezogen und
menschlich fair und angenehm der Sache
das schätze ich sehr vielen Dank
und wir kommen auch mit diesem
Bundeshaushalt zu sehr großen
Ergebnissen denn wir haben ja auch
schwere Krisenzeiten indem wir diesen
Haushalt aufstellen wir lassen in diesen
harten Zeit in der Kälte niemanden
allein das haben setzen wir mit dem
Bundeshaushalt um mit insgesamt 300
Milliarden Euro Entlastungen wie
unterstützen Bürgerinnen und Bürger wir
unterstützen Unternehmen Industrie
soziale Einrichtungen und Vereine wir
nehmen unsere große internationale
Verantwortung waren den wir noch mal
zwei Milliarden zusätzlich fürs
Auswärtige Amt und das
Entwicklungsministerium bereitstellen
und der Finanzminister das angesprochen
wenn man die finanziellen Transaktionen
aus dem Bundeshaushalt rausrechnen was
man ehrlicher Haushalte da machen muss
dann haben wir immer noch 50 Milliarden
Investitionen im Kernhaushalt dann haben
wir auch Sondervermögen digitale
Infrastruktur und dem Klima
transformationsfall insgesamt 30
Milliarden zusätzliche Investitionen
also 80 Milliarden Euro die in
Klimaschutz gehen in Transformation
gehen in Digitalisierung in
Energieeffizienz in Infrastruktur wir
investieren entschlossen mit diesem
Haushalt gegen diese Krisen
das ist der Haushalt von Regierung und
den Koalitionsfraktionen und dann bin
ich bei der Rolle der Opposition ohne
missfreundlich zu sagen die Opposition
ist in diesem Haushaltsverfahren
deutlich unter ihren Möglichkeiten
geblieben
es haben schon mehrere reden und Redner
angedeutet wir haben eine sehr
interessante haushaltswoche erlebt wo
viele Rede und Redner der CDU und CSU
immer mehr gefordert haben mehr Ausgaben
hier dort erhöhen hier mehr ausgeben das
war zu wenig und gleichzeitig gab es
keine Gegenfinanzierung in den
allermeisten Fällen und dann haben wir
heute wieder gehört von Herrn Müller und
von anderen dass wir viel zu viele
Schulden machen würden ehrlich gesagt
das ist nicht logisch und das ist nicht
konsistent Liebe Union
und wenn wir schon beim Thema
rekordschulen sind dann will ich erstens
festhalten höchste schuldenermächtigung
im Bundeshaushalt mit 600 Milliarden
Euro gab es 2020 für den
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds und das
Wort in der Regierung von Angela Merkel
das ist die Wahrheit
und zur Wahrheit gehört auch Grüne und
FDP hätten sich damals auch leicht
machen können 2020 in Opposition wir
hätten es ist leicht machen können und
sagen können wir sind eine Opposition
wir machen diese Rekordschulden nicht
mit und wir polymisieren dagegen haben
wir das gemacht haben das Grüne FDP
gemacht nein wir haben dafür gestimmt
und warum haben wir das gemacht weil wir
nicht in einer schweren Krise in einer
schweren Pandemie gesagt haben wir
machen es billiger Oppositionspolitik
sondern wir haben unser
staatspolitischen Verantwortung
gestanden das ist die Wahrheit
ganz anders jetzt die CDU und CSU nach
Angela Merkel in der Opposition wo jetzt
Friedrich Merzig kapitänsbin übernommen
hat und sich im Populismus versucht je
nachdem woher gerade der Wind weht sie
haben lautstark energiehilfen gefordert
gleichzeitig haben sie die Finanzierung
der 200 Milliarden für den Strom und
gaspreisbremse abgelehnt und sie haben
uns nicht verraten welche andere
Alternative Finanzierung sehen wollen
was wollen Sie ein gerechte
Steuererhöhung wollen Sie bei der Rente
kürzen wir wissen es nicht sie haben
sich verraten was sie machen wollen und
ehrlich gesagt so geht es nicht wenn es
nach der Union gegangen wäre hätten wir
keine Finanzierung für die großen
energiehilfen die die Menschen jetzt
brauchen würden kein Cent denken bei den
hohen Strompreisen einen hohen
Gaspreisen wir sind der Union nicht im
Verfahren gefolgt und es ist richtig
dass sie in der Opposition sind
wir haben diesen Haushalt in sehr
schweren Krisenzeiten aufgestellt
und gleichzeitig versuchen wir auch mit
diesem Haushalt und mit der Politik die
wir machen jetzt auch Zuversicht zu
geben und das können wir auch Russland
ist in der Defensive trotz des schweren
Krieges in der Ukraine als international
immer mehr isoliert das haben wir dann
20-gipfel gesehen wir haben 300
Milliarden Euro Entlastung die wir jetzt
finanzieren die Strom- und Gaspreise
sinken wieder wir haben
rekordinvestitionen für Klima und
Transformation frau Präsidentin ich weiß
Sie haben die Kapitänsbinde hier auf dem
Hohen Haus ich komme zum Schluss wir
wollen Zuversicht geben mit diesem
Haushalt und Mut für die anstehenden
Krisen vielen Dank ihr für die Zusage
Sven Christian Kindler für die Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen deren
haushaltspolitischer Sprecher wir nähern
uns so langsam dem Ende dieser Debatte
Jannik Buri aus der Unionsfraktion ist
Obmann im Unterausschuss zu Fragen der
Europäischen Union und der spielt ja
durchaus eine Rolle weil viele
sondertöpfe die die Bundesregierung
angelegt hat rund um den Bundeshaushalt
in der EU durchaus umstritten sind
politisch der Inflation in diesem Land
entgegenwirken wollen stattdessen die
öffentliche Nachfrage weiter hochhalten
damit im Zweifel Inflation weiter
treiben Herr Minister sie haben von
rekordinvestitionen gesprochen sie haben
nicht davon gesprochen dass auch die
konstruktiven Ausgaben des Staates bei
Ihnen auf einem Rekordniveau liegen vor
allem denen wir Ihren Haushalt aber
deswegen auch ab weil der Bundeshaushalt
für 2023 die finanzpolitische Realität
in diesem Land nicht widerspiegelt Herr
Minister sie sagen dass sie nach drei
Jahren den Bundeshaushalt in eine Lage
der Normalität zurückführen würden die
Schuldenbremse wieder einhalten wollen
sie haben da heute deutlich tiefer
gestartet als in der Vergangenheit aus
meiner Sicht auch richtiger Weise so
denn oft verschweigen Sie dabei dass sie
in diesem Jahr 360 Milliarden Euro sich
vom Bundestag haben genehmigen lassen in
Sondervermögen um die Politik für die
nächsten Jahre durchzuffinanzieren und
vor allem und das ist viel
weitreichender verschweigen Sie dass Sie
mit diesem Vorgehen Rücklagen zu bilden
in der Notsituation unter der
notlagenklauseln der Schuldenbremse die
Blaupause geschaffen haben wie sie wie
kommende Finanzminister wie im übrigen
auch die Länder die Schuldenbremse
künftig immer dann umgehen können wenn
Regierungskoalitionen das wollen und
dass sie mit diesem Vorgehen diese
Blaupause geliefert haben das zeigt sich
nicht nur daran dass sie dieses Vorgehen
dieses Jahr zweimal angewendet haben
sondern dass wir jetzt auch schon die
ersten Bundesländer sehen die so handeln
wenn man in der Saarland schaut wenn man
nach Niedersachsen schaut und Herr
Minister sie wollen mit diesem
Bundeshaushalt den Eindruck erwecken der
Verteidiger der Schuldenbremse zu sein
tatsächlich steht stand heute zu
befürchten dass Sie damit dass Sie diese
Blaupause erfunden haben in die
Wirtschaftsgeschichte der Bundesrepublik
eingehen werden als der Finanzminister
der den Weg gebannt hat wie die
Schuldenbremse und gegangen werden kann
sie haben Herr Minister als Liberaler
Finanzminister in einem Jahr Amtszeit
das geschafft an dem ihr
sozialdemokratischer Vorgänger vier
Jahre lang am Widerstand der Union
gescheitert ist nämlich die
Schuldenbremse auszuhüllen und die
Glaubwürdigkeit der Schuldenbremse zu
untergraben und daran ändert auch die
Argumentation nichts dass sie die
Schulden zur Krisenbewältigung vom
regulären Haushalt von den regulären
Ausgaben trennen wollen jetzt kann ich
ja durchaus verstehen dass sie um ihre
Koalitionspartner im Zaum halten zu
können bei den ausgabenwünschen von SPD
und Grünen die allerlei Ideen haben für
was die eigentlich für Krisenbewältigung
vorgesehene Mittel stattdessen
ausgegeben werden sollten dass sie da
ein Instrument brauchen um ihre
Koalitionspartner in Zaum zu halten sie
haben das selber gerade eben
Selbstbindung genannt und es mag für den
einen oder anderen hier auch
überraschend klingen aber man kann auch
ohne eine solche Trennung der beiden
ausgabenarten im regulären
Bundeshaushalt Ausgaben transpar
darstellen sparsam mit Steuergeld
umgehen und mehr Ausgaben damit weitere
Schulden vermeiden das würde allerdings
voraussetzen
Prioritäten zu setzen denn das würde
erfordern dass sie angesichts der
aktuellen Krisen die sie ihr
richtigerweise ansprechen kostspielige
Projekte ihres Koalitionsvertrages erst
einmal hinten anstellen und um an der
Stelle auch mit einer agentenbildung
aufzuräumen die auch heute hier wieder
oft geäußert worden sind wie man
priorisieren kann wie das geht das haben
wir Ihnen allein in der
Bereinigungssitzung mit 370
Änderungsanträgen gezeigt die sie alles
samt abgelehnt haben und damit 19
Milliarden Einsparpotenzial noch dazu
generiert haben und Herr Minister
ich sehe ich sehe durchaus wie sie wie
ihr Haus wie auch ihre Fraktion versucht
den Bundeshaushalt zusammenzuhalten das
würde es allerdings dann auch nötig
machen dass sie sich als Finanzminister
in dieser Regierung die kapitänsbinder
anziehen sich gegen ihre
Koalitionspartner durchsetzen was sie
stattdessen tun ist die Glaubwürdigkeit
der Schuldenbremse zu unterwandern um
den ohnehin brüchigen Burgfrieden in
ihrer Koalition zu erhalten ihre
Kolleginnen und Kollegen im Gefüge einer
Volkswirtschaft ist der Staat kein
unabhängiger Dritter der unbegrenzt Geld
schaffen Geld schöpfen kann um damit
unbegrenzt zu verteilen und alles zu
kompensieren was wortwirtschaftlich
gerade passiert die Aufgabe von
Haushaltspolitik ist es stattdessen ein
Teil dessen was erwirtschaftet worden
ist politisch sinnvoll im Land
umzuverteilen umgehen wir die
Schuldenbremse und finanzieren wir
Ausgaben dauerhaft mit Schulden eben in
den Weg Ausgaben dauerhaft mit Schulden
zu finanzieren dann heißt das am Ende
nichts anderes als dass wir Geld
ausgeben was nicht erwirtschaftet worden
ist und was kommende Generationen erst
noch werden erwirtschaften müssen und in
diesem Zusammenhang ist dieser
Bundeshaushalt über den wir heute
abstimmen keine Trendwende in der
Finanzpolitik der Ampel es ist
stattdessen ein weiteres Puzzleteil in
einem Gesamtgefüge von Finanz- und
Haushaltspolitik die auf Rekordschulden
und die auf eine Unterwanderung der
Schuldenbremse abzielt und eingesetzt
dessen angesichts dessen dass Sie den
Weg dafür bereitet haben wie heute und
die Zukunft Bund und Länder im Zweifel
die Schuldenbremse umgehen können werde
ich lieber Otto Fricke nicht mit
Shakespeare Enten sondern stattdessen
mit Goethe denn wenn wir sehen was jetzt
auch manche Länder beginnen Herr
Minister dann könnte man sagen sind sie
gewissermaßen der Zauberlehrling der
kreativen Buchführung um die
Schuldenbremse herum und deswegen hoffe
ich inständig dass wir nicht bald von
ihren und aus ihren Reihen hören Geburt
ist groß die ich rief die Geister werde
ich nicht mehr los vielen Dank
die Jannik Burri endet mit Goethe an
diesem letzten Tag der haushaltswoche in
der letzten Runde zum Bundeshaushalt
2023 wir sind beim vorletzten Redner
angekommen Martin Gerster kommt aus der
SPD-Fraktion und ist Vorsitzender im
Rechnungsprüfungsausschuss
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen Kollegen wir und ich denke
das sollten wir auch mal festhalten in
dieser Debatte können froh sein dass wir
es durch das engagierte Handeln des
Bundeskanzlers der Regierungsmannschaft
und der Ampel tatsächlich schaffen ohne
fossile Brennstoffe aus Russland durch
den Winter zu kommen es ist gut das Olaf
Scholz die Kapitänsbinde dieser
Bundesregierung trägt nicht nur aber
auch finanziell verlangt uns die Krise
mit allen ihren Auswirkungen viel ab und
die Ampel hier auf Bundesebene tut alles
dass wir die vielen Herausforderungen
bewältigt bekommen wir nehmen dafür
wirklich viel Geld in die Hand ich
erinnere an das Bundes an die Bundeswehr
100 Milliarden Euro Sondervermögen ich
denke an 200 Milliarden Euro für den
wirtschaftlichen Abwehrschirm damit
Energierechnungen bezahlbar bleiben und
an drei entlastungspakete in Höhe von
rund 100 Milliarden Euro damit alle
Menschen durch die Krise bekommen ich
denke an die milliardenschwere
Unterstützung des Bundes für die
Kommunen bei der Unterbringung von
geflüchteten aus der Ukraine und
anderswo ich denke allen die dreiviertel
Milliarde die wir für Integrationskurse
zur Verfügung stellen an die Erhöhung
des Kindergeldes und dann vieles mehr an
Wohngeld Plus an die energiepauschale
und und und und ja wir können es
hinkriegen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen aber nur dann wenn alle
politischen Ebenen mit anpacken und hier
finde ich kommen wir zu einem ganz
entscheidenden Punkt den während wir uns
hier auf Bundesebene in der Ampel Arme
und Beine ausreißen macht sich so manche
Landesregierung einen schlanken Fuß und
lieber Kollege Janik Buri da komme ich
zum Beispiel Baden-Württemberg Steuer
mehr Einnahmen im Milliarden höre
Haushaltsüberschüsse in Milliardenhöhe
ja die Zeiten sind schlecht aber die
Kassenlage im Landeshaushalt
Baden-Württemberg ist ausgezeichnet aber
eigene Hilfsprogramme eigenes Engagement
in der Krise weitgehend Fehlanzeige
stattdessen Maut man und mosert man in
Stuttgart an der Bundesregierung und der
Ampel rum zu dem kriegt das Kritik wenn
der Bund nicht mehr in vollem Umfang
ureigene Landesaufgaben mit finanziert
und hier müssen wir ich glaube das sind
wir alle gefragt die schon vorhandene
Schieflage müssen wir aufpassen dass
diese nicht vollkommen aus dem Ruder
läuft und hier sehe ich wirklich uns
alle in diesem Haus und auf Bundesebene
gefordert die Meldung aus Stuttgart von
heute morgen finde ich passen ins Bild
die Landesregierung Baden-Württemberg
für die Bundesgelder zu Unterstützung
für die Unterbringung von geflüchteten
nicht zu hundert Prozent an die Kommunen
weiterleiten und lehnt die Aufnahme von
gefährdeten Menschen auf aus Afghanistan
über unser bundesaufnahmeprogramm ab so
die zuständige Landesministerin in einem
Schreiben an den sie Feser ich finde das
ist nicht solidarisch sondern mindestens
unanständig
zum stellenhaushalt möchte ich auch ganz
gerne noch den ein oder anderen Satz
sagen hierzu hat sich ja zu Beginn
dieser haushaltswoche im Bundestag der
Chef der Unionsfraktion in einer Weise
geäußert die mich doch gelinde gesagt
etwas irritiert hat die Ampel und ihre
Minister hätten angesichts der
zusätzliche Bundeshaushalt vorgesehenen
Stellen ich zitiere Friedrich Merz jedes
Maß verloren da frage ich mich schon
welche Stellen meint eigentlich jetzt
die
Unionsfraktion welche Stellen hält sie
denn für unverzichtbar bei der
Bundespolizei schaffen wir 1000 neue
Stellen etwa zum Schluss der Flug und
Seehäfen oder als Besatzungen auf den
Schiffen in der Nord- und Ostsee wenn
dieses Personal für überflüssig gehalten
wird dann finde ich sollten Sie das auch
ehrlich sagen beispielsweise in der
Bereinigungssitzung oder auch in der
Debatte innen wir jedenfalls von der SPD
und in der Ampel halten dieses Personal
in dieser Krise nicht bürgerverzichtbar
sie sind absolut richtig
180 Stellen beim BKA zur Bekämpfung von
organisierter Kriminalität von
Extremismus und für den Kampf gegen
Kindesmissbrauch das sind Fachleute die
dringend benötigt werden das ist
jedenfalls unsere Meinung und keine
überflüssigen stellen auch beim WBK 146
neue Stellen stehen im Haushalt zu
Umsetzung der Neuaufstellung wir finden
vollkommen zu Recht während der damalige
Innenminister Horst Seehofer ihrem
bbk-chef Arm mit Schuster damals keine
einzige zusätzliche Stelle dafür zu
gestanden hat laut Opposition machen wir
ja fast überall zu wenig aber das
notwendige Personal soll dann aber auch
nicht eingestellt werden ich finde das
ist unseriös und verantwortungslos
angesichts der aktuellen
Herausforderungen also letztendlich muss
man sagen ein guter Haushalt auch der
stellenausfall passt und deswegen bitte
ich für die spd-fra sind für die Ampel
um Zustimmung herzlichen Dank
Martin Gerster aus der SPD-Fraktion noch
mal mit einem Verweis auf wie er sagt
die ausgezeichnete Kassenlage in Ländern
wie Baden-Württemberg und zu
zusätzlichen Stellen die die Ampel
genehmigt hat letzte Rednerin Elisabeth
Kaiser aus der SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Bürgerinnen und bürgerwerke Kolleginnen
und Kollegen wir sind kurz davor ein
Bundeshaushalt in Höhe von mehr als 476
Milliarden Euro zu beschließen und die
Debatten in der vergangenen Tagen die
haben deutlich gezeigt auch in
herausfordernden Zeiten packt diese
Koalition wichtige Aufgaben an und sorgt
gleichzeitig für finanzielle Stabilität
aber anstatt wie die cdu/csu hervorriehe
harte das Mantra des spardiktats und
vermeintlicher Generationengerechtigkeit
vor sich herzutragen investieren wir als
Ampelkoalition in soziale Gerechtigkeit
und gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt
die Erhöhungen des Mindestlohns auf 12
Euro das Kindergeldes ist Wohngeld das
Heizkostenzuschüsse Direktzahlungen
Steuererleichterungen Strom und
gaspreisbremse all das sind doch
Maßnahmen die spürbar bei den Menschen
ankommen als Sozialdemokratinnen wissen
wir das soziale Sicherheit das Fundament
ist für unseren gesellschaftlichen
Zusammenhalt und genau das unterscheidet
uns von Ihnen liebe Union beim
Bürgergeld da haben sie bewiesen welches
Menschenbild ihre Politik prägt wenn die
Menschen ohne Arbeit gegen jede mit
geringen Einkommen ausspielen als
Ostdeutsche möchte ich mal klar sagen
ich bin sehr froh dass wir mit den
Bürgergeld endlich Hartz IV überwinden
dann Hartz IV hat gerade im Osten
hunderte Menschen in prekäre
Beschäftigung gebracht aus der nur viele
schwer oder gar nicht wieder
herausgekommen sind und das nicht selten
obwohl sie einen viel bessere
Qualifizierung hatten
mit dem Burger Geld da geht es nämlich
nicht länger darum Arbeitssuchende in
irgendeiner Arbeit zu drängen sondern
zielgerichtet zu unterstützen neue
berufliche Wege zu gehen und das ist für
uns auch eine Frage des Respekts
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen mit dem
zur Abstimmung stehenden Haushalt holen
wir nach was mit der Union liegen
geblieben ist und stellen gleichzeitig
die drängenden Fragen unserer Zeit wir
investieren in Klimaschutz die
Transformation unserer Wirtschaft die
Digitalisierung wir erhöhen die Mittel
für Forschung und Entwicklung gerade
auch die Gunsten der kleine
mittelständischen Wirtschaft und wir
kümmern uns um eine moderne
Verkehrsinfrastruktur wenn wir wollen
unseren Kindern kein marodes Land ohne
Perspektive hinterlassen das ist für uns
Generationengerechtigkeit liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und wenn es um Zukunftsfähigkeit geht
dann kommen wir auch an der Frage des
Fach- und Arbeitskräftemangels hier
nicht vorbei und Saskia Essen hat das
sehr bezeichnet hier auch im Plenum am
Mittwoch als die Achillesferse unserer
Wirtschaft beschrieben und besonders in
Ostdeutschland in Regionen die bis heute
mit Abwanderung zu kämpfen haben
gefährdet eben der Mangel an Fach und
Arbeitskräften die wirtschaftliche
Entwicklung und es freut mich deshalb
sehr dass wir neben vielen Maßnahmen das
Fachkräfte Sicherung in diesem Haushalt
auch Mittel für den Aufbau der German
professional school in Thüringen
bereitstellen ein innovatives
Modellprojekt für die dauerhafte
Gewinnung ausländischer Fachkräfte in
Deutschland
und so gehen wir das an wir geben
Perspektive haben Mut machen Mut und vor
allen Dingen bewegt begegnen wir den
Menschen mit Respekt und auf Augenhöhe
und mit Vertrauen und an Vertrauen an in
die engagierte Zivilgesellschaft da
fehlt es leider bei der Union leider
auch bei vielen anderen auf der rechten
Seite des Plenums das musste ich in den
haushaltsgesprächen zu den
demokratieförderprogrammen leider immer
wieder feststellen damit unterstützen
wir doch dabei engagierte in vielen
Vereinen und Verbänden die sich stark
machen für unsere Demokratie und
Zusammenhalt egal ob in der Freiwilligen
Feuerwehr in der Gewerkschaftsjugend
oder eben auch im Freundeskreis für
Flüchtlinge in Gera sie alle machen
dieses Land auch in Krisenzeiten machen
Sie es fest sie haben lebenswert und
vielfältig und stehen diese Kräfte gegen
die Kräfte auf dieser Seite des Plenums
und zum Ende bleibt man ja nur noch
einmal kurz Danke zu sagen an die lieben
Kolleginnen und Kollegen für die gute
Zusammenarbeit im Haushaltsausschuss an
Helge braun unseren
Ausschussvorsitzenden und vor allen
Dingen auch an die Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeiter im Ausschuss und besonderer
Dank noch mal an Dennis Rode der für die
SPD-Fraktion die Kapitänsbinde in den
Haushaltsverhandlungen trägt heute
leider nicht hier sein kann gute
Besserung lieber Dennis und nun einer
gute Abstimmung zum Bundeshaushalt
vielen Dank
Elisabeth Kaiser die die letzte Rednerin
war in dieser haushaltswoche am Dienstag
ist es ja losgegangen um 10 Uhr heute
jetzt also das Ende es wird noch meinen
namentlich abgestimmt über den
Bundeshaushalt 2023 es geht um
476,3 Milliarden Euro aber das ist nur
fast die halbe Wahrheit denn es gibt ja
auch noch mal jede Menge zusätzliche
Schulden in der sonderschulde Bundeswehr
beispielsweise im Wirtschaft
Stabilisierungsfonds oder im Klima und
transformationsform also es wird sehr
viel mehr Geld bereitgestellt als dass
der Bundeshaus fürs nächste Jahr hergibt
da wird es noch weitere Diskussionen zu
geben wie gesagt hier jetzt gleich die
namentliche Abstimmung aufgerufen von
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin Petra Pau es
gab am Morgen hier schon einen wichtigen
debattenpunkt außerhalb der
haushaltswoche nämlich die Abstimmung
zum Ergebnis des Vermittlungsausschusses
zum Bürgergeld es gab eine große
Mehrheit in eine große Mehrheit dazu
eben
Parlament aber es gab dann anschließend
auch Beratung und Abstimmung dazu im
Bundesrat und auch damit werden wir uns
natürlich ausführlich beschäftigen alles
weitere dazu sagte ihm jetzt Alexander
Keller